Thin nose anymore.
It behooved me.
Yeah.
Have you ever looked at like a virgo
does ears?
Yeah.
They were big ears and the nose grow.
They keep growing.
Yeah.
Age is a very annoying thing.
Well,
that's a weird one.
It's almost like to let someone know
like,
Hey,
look at this guy's proportions are all
fucked up.
He's got bad juice.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
So how do I reduce.
I wanted to get an ear reduction and a
nose sharpening.
I'm sure people have done that.
I could only imagine if girls are
getting will grow.
That's a different one.
A big ass heroine is here.
Hey.
He's not 12 shaved those years.
You know,
I've,
I've got hair growing out of my ears.
I have to.
I have to put a tremor in vain.
I pluck my.
Yeah,
if I see hair that doesn't belong
somewhere I have.
I'll take it out.
Go Wax it.
My father like he lets his nose hair
grow.
Has your eyebrows micro?
Would it kill you to.
Can you.
I'm looking into your nose and stuff.
It's a nest father,
bro.
Yeah,
sometimes I get so mad at him because
the way he eats sometimes,
like we were in Mexico and he uh,
he was just show up,
you got to breakfast,
he has his belly and he's got like,
he's got four French toast and a waffle
and a banana and I,
and I'm just sitting there and I get so
mad.
And then I started texting him.
I texted him,
I said,
listen man,
you got to start changing the way you
eat.
And I go and I'm angry as I'm texting
this,
I'm getting more angry,
more angry.
So stop the bullshit and start eating.
No,
I was so angry.
I had to tell them that I'm getting,
my heart was beating.
I was furious.
I couldn't text faster.
I go get it together,
get it together and stop eating
bullshit.
And would it kill you to fucking move a
little bit?
Bang.
I just sent that.
Oh yeah.
Strong.
I don't want him to die.
Does he exercise at all?
Fuck.
No.
And I'll tell you why.
When he was young,
he was poor and he had to do manual
labor.
He had to work construction.
He had to do everything with his hands,
so now that he has money,
it reminds him of one,
if you asked him to do shit,
if you ask him to help you with a table,
it reminds him of when he was poor and
how awful it was.
I was reading a book once on power
lifting.
One of the things that they suggested is
getting a manual labor job.
That's when you have to move furniture.
Okay.
When you got to carry couches upstairs.
Yeah.
That'll never saw that.
I never saw anybody actually recommend
that someone do that in order to get
stronger.
Well,
when you,
um,
my friend who we wrestled and played
football at a high level,
they used to work the farm and they
would,
there was a thing where you would take
hay and you would run after the truck
trucks.
I'll you take the hay and you throw it
off and I guess you'd just doing that.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
you know,
you can crazy.
I worked construction one summer in,
uh,
in Washington dc in the 95 degree heat
and I had to dig a foundation for a
building for a house,
just dig into the ground all day and
then we had to,
we had to demolish a house and take that
debris,
put it into a truck and then drive it to
a landfill called lot and I think and
then we would,
and we take it off the truck.
So that movement of digging and then
like the demolition and digging and
piling it in a truck and then piling it
off a truck.
You're too exhausted to do a goddamn
thing.
You're not working out after that.
If you do work out and you get used to
it though,
I think that's the idea is that your
body becomes way more resilient.
That's what he was saying.
If you could get a job because a mason
or some sort of manual labor on a
construction site.
We carrying lumber.
You just lifting things up.
Karen Reynolds have your body will just
naturally gets stronger.
The strongest I've ever felt in my life.
And Jujitsu was a Mexican guy who was
amazing.
Oh yeah,
man.
I couldn't move.
Rick's man.
I couldn't believe how.
How has nothing worked on them.
Just imagine like picking up bricks all
day long.
Scanning bricks.
Everything will just get stronger.
Yeah.
I worked with a guy named Boo Jack in
DC.
Boo Jack.
What giant black guy who was a mason.
Does that two words or one word just
called himself bootjack.
I called him Boo and he go who?
Jack?
That was probably as one name,
right?
Yup.
Last name or his first name?
I think it was his whole name.
Bluejack brand name.
It's a superhero or something.
He should be here.
Just a giant.
Very,
very friendly.
Jolly black men with the biggest,
strongest hands I've ever seen.
He was a mason speaking of big jolly
black men with one name.
Uh,
I met Sinbad the other day.
I've never met before.
I met him in a parking lot.
Our cars were right next to each other.
Fully random.
Just fully random.
What was he wearing?
Was He wearing a dangly earring?
A check.
Was He.
Was he dressed in a colorful manner or.
No,
he was very understated and seemed a
completely normal.
Like I don't remember what he was
wearing.
He might be wearing what you're wearing
right now.
He always struck me as a nice,
very,
very nice guy.
Very nice guy.
And what's he doing now?
Doing standup.
Still touring?
Yeah.
You know,
still got an audience.
Oh yeah.
He's a funny dude,
man.
Apparently he was really funny on kill
Tony.
They did a kill Tony episode and Sinbad
side end is one of the um,
the guest judges.
Yeah.
You know,
they have a new guest every week and
they said he was killer.
He had to do to have been doing it for
that long.
They've got some tricks up their sleeve.
It's a real comic.
It's been around forever.
Been communicating with an audience for
a long time,
but it's just nice to meet him in it and
see that he's a nice guy.
You know,
those guys.
You ever met anybody who was not so
nice?
If I did the wrong way maybe five years
ago,
I would have told you.
Yeah.
But now I'm like,
why?
Why,
why bring heat on someone from some
weird moment that I probably could have
done myself if I was true.
If you've run into someone and you're in
the wrong head space,
maybe you just got done,
somebody yelled at you and maybe you
have a business deal that went bad.
Maybe you got cut off on the highway.
You never know when you're running into
people.
It's just we vary so much liquid.
We would like to encourage each other to
be on a good track all the time,
but I think we need a little bit more
forgiveness when someone does something
stupid.
I'm going to call my next special,
I think bipolar ape because that is what
we are.
We are men and if you stop and you
freeze frame on somebody when they're
having a moment,
you can catch them in any like that
whole spectrum,
the human spectrum center in St and
anything in between.
You can catch them in a terrible moment
or a great moment,
but you can't decide that that's what
they are all the time and that's what
we're doing.
Now.
Let's get to that.
We quantify certain things that are just
dumb,
like there's certain things you just
never,
you're just not going to bounce back
from the Rachel Dolezal thing,
which she pretended she was black but
trialist and black much.
You know what I'm saying?
But there's like those things where it
becomes a nationwide thing and I bet
she's a lovely lady.
I Dunno,
I have no idea.
That might be empathy gone wild or that
might be sort of this,
this,
uh,
I think a lot of times everybody wants
to be an individual.
They want that.
That's always been a problem with the
human condition,
right?
You want to,
you want to be,
you want to be unique.
We all do,
right?
Even though we all believe in equality,
we all want to be not equal.
We want to be a little better than the
next guy,
or at least unique.
And that's maybe where competition comes
from itself.
But I think sometimes people negotiate
that issue and that problem with a,
with a very clumsy apparatus with a
really weird way of doing it.
I'm going to be trans racial or I'm
gonna.
I'm going to wear dishes in my ears and,
and,
and literally cover my whole face with
tattoos.
That's fine.
Super Common.
There might.
Yeah.
That might be a better way to negotiate
that,
that problem you're having because it's
a,
it's still pretty surface.
You have a look at the Hashtag face
tattoo on instagram.
No.
Holy Shit.
There's a lot of people get in their
face tattooed like it's like what?
Slow down,
slow down.
It goes back to wanting to be seen.
Well,
I think what you're saying makes a lot
of sense in terms of like people wanting
to belong to a group that seems cool and
like black people seem like overall a
cool group,
right?
Like you have good music behind it.
They have a funny way of talking.
They have all these amazing pro
athletes.
They have a totally different kind of
culture and you identify with that
culture but you can't get in because
you're a white girl.
You're like,
Shit.
It's also something.
I think also there's a romance to when
you're on the outside looking in it
struggle.
Oh yeah.
And I'm being having been oppressed and
all those things.
And yet you yet you triumph,
yet you find a way to be funny,
yet you find a way to be colorful,
yet you find a way to be artistic.
Rap came from from,
from the South Bronx.
While it was literally on fire.
Yeah.
And rap is just one aspect of it.
Right?
I mean think about it.
Some of the very best stand up
Comedians,
some of the very best musicians.
And we think of the percentage of the
population that's black,
12 percent the percentage that become
elite professional athletes mean what is
the percentage of NBA players that are
black?
It's something crazy.
A lot of it's also just.
What is it you think?
I don't know,
but it's pretty high.
I mean 69 personally.
Probably something.
I don't know why I said that number.
Jamie,
are you a lot of it might be just also
that there are two.
There are two avenues open to you in a
lot of black communities.
At least it's changing,
but you know it was sports and music for
sure.
That's.
That probably plays a part in it,
no doubt about it,
but it's also there's a sort of
extraordinary number of professional
athletes like elite athletes.
Yeah.
That just happened to be black.
And what is that though?
Is it genetic?
Is it,
is it the environment that are coming
from.
I mean it's,
it's a fascinating thing to be explored
because for all this talk of racism,
if you just want to be really honest,
there's a lot of African Americans that
have some pretty phenomenal genetic
traits like fit,
like Carl,
like think of like who's like Jamie,
who was like the biggest freak all time?
A athlete basketball player.
Would it be probably the Bron Jim Bron
James Probably.
Right.
And then you have Michael Jordan is
another freak athlete,
right?
I mean how many of those guys like that
stuff?
Because people would argue like Larry
Bird,
but it was a phenomenal shooter,
but he wasn't the kind of freak
athletes.
Lebron is Dr Jay Jordan would use to
literally fly,
fly through the air.
There are a couple of guys that can do
things like that,
but they don't have the overall.
Yeah.
Well,
so,
so if you look at,
there's a book called the sports gene
that talks about this.
If you look at Africa,
it's,
it's probably the most genetically is
the most genetically diverse part of the
world,
right?
I mean,
the Africans from the bar for coast are
totally different in the Africans from,
from say the highlands of Kenya,
Ethiopia,
the Africans from the Sudan,
the Dinka and the new attend to be
almost seven,
six,
sometimes.
Certainly seven feet is not that
uncommon in many people don't realize
Egypt,
supportive Africa very much so.
I mean the Tunisia,
Morocco,
that's more Arabic,
right?
Um,
uh,
but then you've got,
I mean,
it's fascinating.
This is really,
it was,
and let's go to Ethiopia,
Ethiopia,
they grow to an average height,
a beautiful people.
There was a lot of trade and that side
of the world,
the Eritrea,
they're dead.
They've been renowned for their beauty.
If you just step over the border,
just just go right to just one,
one south or one north.
You are going into Sudan and south
Sudan,
tallest people in the world.
Talls people in the world.
And I mean,
some of them can be like a fist off at
eight feet,
that's where like new bowl and those
people came from,
okay,
if you go just another country,
just one more country east,
now you're in the Congo and that's home
to the pygmy.
So you've got the shortest people in the
world in one country and then just cross
the border,
one of the tallest in the world in that
country.
So Africa is insanely diverse.
But if you look at the athletes with the
most explosive power,
and if you like that,
that includes the fast people in the
world who are in Jamaica and who are,
um,
you know,
in the United States,
genetically,
you can trace them back to a very primal
marilee.
You can trace them back,
very small part of Africa according to
this book,
the sports gene,
which is the Africa most,
um,
and so that is where,
that's where you'll see the fastest,
most explosive people.
However,
having said that,
you can hear it deion sanders talking,
watching this white running back 215
pounds.
He ran a four,
three,
5:40.
And he was like,
I can't say this on tv,
but he can run,
run,
run.
And it was true.
It was like,
you haven't seen a white guy run a four,
three,
five in forever.
It's pretty rare.
There's gotta be some Viking genes
floating room.
Sure.
But there,
there is no,
I don't think there's any black
quarterbacks in the NFL,
quarterbacks cornerbacks.
It's just fascinating when you stop and
think about just the sheer number of
people involved in professional
athletics,
the sheer number of people that make a
living playing a game with their body.
Yeah.
But I don't know if that kind of
athleticism helps you become a champion
in tennis.
You know,
there are different.
Depends on the sport and sports
specific.
Right?
Well,
I mean first of all,
black people historically have not been
into tennis because they didn't have
money.
It's Arthur Ashe was obviously Athena,
but Arthur Ashe was like way before
they're telling.
Right.
So he was like the groundbreaker.
But how many mean now?
I'm sure a lot of kids growing up in
Nice communities,
they have tennis clubs and stuff like
that.
African American kids.
But it's less a thing of that culture.
The thing like there's not a lot of
Italian American tennis players either.
You know what I'm saying?
Like my people don't play tennis,
they don't get into tennis.
It's not an economic thing.
It's just a cultural of the same way.
Yeah.
So when you see all these like world
class tennis players,
it just happened to be of the,
you know,
rich upper crease coach.
You need a lot of stuff with tennis.
You know,
it's a lot going on at tennis plus
nobody gives a shit until you're really
good.
You know,
like if you're kind of like,
if you have a chance,
holy plays a Semipro ball for,
oh maybe we'll get into the big leagues,
you know?
But if you don't,
if you like obviously my pro tennis
player get a fucking job,
bitch,
what are you doing?
You playing tennis?
It takes a long time.
I used to know this dude who was a
professional racquetball player and that
was the grind nerdiest of all grinds
because when I was 19 I recognize like,
oh no,
this dude done painted himself into a
corner.
He's like a world champion.
It's something nobody gives a fuck.
Nobody cares dude.
Nobody cared.
And people would treat him like,
Oh,
poor guy.
Like that was part of it.
It was like he's awesome but poor guy.
Well I feel like way when I watched the
biathlon picks and shit or curling or.
Yeah,
the sports will curling is,
don't talk shit about curling in
Newfoundland.
If you go up there and Canada,
they get fucking angry at you.
I don't give a fuck.
They get mad.
So I don't care that you replayed the
curling move in slow motion.
I didn't miss it in regular motion.
You know,
there's just certain sports.
I don't think their skills are not
sports.
Like what?
Uh,
how to races,
how to racist deal with the fact that
there's so many elite black athletes.
What is it?
Because you just look at it and how do
you see white superiority in that many.
I've heard,
I've heard guys in New York,
white guys would always say this about,
about I'd hear white dudes in there talk
about black and white athletes like
this.
They'd be like,
well he's brother.
So obviously he's going to be faster and
stronger,
but this kid over here has got heart and
he's got smarts and then so like guys
who apparently got heart brain,
whereas the black guy only has muscle.
It was a clear indication that you're
just,
it was such a racist kind of way of
delineating,
you know,
what's also delusional because people
want to assume that because someone has
physical attributes,
they don't have mental attributes,
they always want to say that.
And sometimes it's true because
sometimes when you have physical
attributes,
life is easier for you and you get soft.
You don't have to work as hard.
Like one of the more impressive guys in
the UFC for me has always been Frankie
Edgar because that guy's just a product
of hard work.
He's never been a knockout puncher.
He's not the biggest guys always in
small for whatever division.
He's in a small 55 and he's pretty small
at 45 in comparison to some guys like,
you know,
like Ortega,
we fought this weekend,
right?
Brian's much bigger than.
I'm taller,
longer.
He's just all heart and will and
toughness.
And,
and I love that,
and I think that's an admirable thing
and I think you can get out a lot at a
Washington guy like that,
but it doesn't mean that a guy can't
have that mindset and also have some
fucking ray Lewis body.
Well man,
it's my turn was the example of that.
Nobody and coby Brian was saying,
nobody works harder and that's why they
and they,
they love to win in the almost psychotic
way.
Extreme winters are that way.
Yeah.
That whole thing,
that extreme winters is why we're here
folks.
It's why it's so compelling.
I mean,
you,
you had to have some godly resolve to
get through the Mongol era and the
fucking caveman era and think about all
the different shit that's happened in
between it.
Just think about the people that
colonized this country.
We were so far removed from people who
lived here and rode wagons across the
country just 200 years ago.
Nothing that just happened.
They did this study.
Uh,
Camille Paglia was talking about this.
Why were most of the people that
revolutionized the human condition,
male,
like.
So in other words,
the printing press and Einstein and
copernicus and Galileo and Kepler and
all these people that Kinda like you
know,
and,
and why,
why so few women and so a lot of
academic circles will.
The only single variable answer is that
women were kept down by the Patriarchy
or whatever.
It might be very condescending though if
you think about it,
because that would suggest that women
didn't find their way through the
cracks.
Some of them did,
but for the most part and then there's
some truth to that.
But for the most part,
there's another really interesting
theory that men have.
Men and women tend to have two different
kinds of brains.
We've evolved that do different.
Brian's because women have to watch out
for children and pay attention to the
minutia and keep them away from death.
Whereas men have the kind of brand that
can obsess over just one thing,
even if it doesn't really bare any
relation to the material world.
So they can think about whether time
bends or whether they the the
relationship between time and matter and
space,
you know,
and they'll just delta zero in on that
problem and obsessed over that problem
and you have those extreme winners that
literally to the exclusion of everything
else,
including their family,
including,
you know,
other people focused on just one thing.
But in a lot of ways,
thank God we had that aberration because
that is what revolutionizes,
that is what changes a lot about how we
live a little explosions that make this
thing move quicker there.
The combustion inside the engine that is
human civilization.
Every now and then you get someone that
just is an outlier.
So Elon musk characters drilling holes
under the Los Angeles and building
fucking power stations from,
for solar power.
For People's houses.
Yeah.
Make it fucking cars.
She's never going to work.
It's never going to work.
He's like,
shut up.
He's just so much smarter.
We let them drill under the city.
Will it go ahead.
You know what you're doing.
Everybody just lets him do it.
You imagine if like a regular person
wanted to drill underneath the cities
and make tubes and put,
they'll be like,
that's the dumbest idea ever.
And it dropped down.
A car is going to go on a train and the
train is going to go really fast with
the car underground.
Shut the fuck up.
Should have this guy,
Andrew Keenan,
your podcast.
I interviewed him.
He wrote a book called how to fix the
future and uh,
also a book called the Internet's not
the answer.
And,
and another book called the call to the
amateur and kind of like in the culture,
the Amatory Lichens,
uh,
you know,
the infinite monkey metaphor.
You ever heard that?
Yes.
Yeah,
it's great.
So if you had an infinite number of
monkeys just banging away at a
typewriter,
eventually one of them would,
would type out a masterpiece,
like a shakespearian play or something.
Just randomly,
just randomly.
Yeah.
And as you know,
if that was real and it would end
mathematically,
you can prove it.
I get it mathematically,
but I still call bullshit,
right?
Like,
it doesn't make any sense.
Like what are the odds that just
randomly this monkey on just accident
put the periods in the right place and
the spaces in the right place and the
commas in the right place?
No,
no.
It's impossible.
It is part of the last chance.
Last chance can suck a fat dick.
I don't buy it.
I've heard it before by people far
smarter than me and I'm like,
no,
no.
There's zero chance raises an amazing
question,
right?
What's.
What's amazing is it's like human beings
can actually reach beyond that,
which they can measure human beings.
So it's not just what you can see and
measure.
It's actually what you can imagine and
what you can imagine actually is real.
It's a part of reality and all that
shit.
Yeah,
but he said that these infinite monkeys,
that's basically what youtube and what
the Internet has ushered in.
Right.
But long story short,
when you're talking about Elon Musk,
he was talking about how in his book
had a fixed future.
The nine tech billionaires of the nine
tech billionaires,
they own more wealth than one point 8
billion people on this planet.
We've actually never seen this kind of
concentration of wealth.
Good.
Luckily guys like Jeff Bezos who he
knows really well and uh,
you know,
these other guys like Mark Zuckerberg
are kind of aware.
They have some historical perspective of
where they stand and for the most part
they're doing their best to try to
figure out a way to be responsible with
this wealth.
There's also the fact that they're
coming from a tech background,
which has historically been really
fucking smart people.
Right.
Those are the innovators.
So because of that,
they're more left leaning.
Yeah.
Which is probably for what,
it's just the whole tech community is
more left leaning.
Yeah,
I mean that's why any,
anything that deviates from that,
it's kind of punished.
Well,
the problem though is that now you have
the four riders of the apocalypse,
Google,
facebook,
Amazon,
and apple.
There's so much that,
I mean,
the amount of co they have,
they had access to all your data and to
the maps.
So it does kind of go.
You kind of go,
okay,
your left leaning,
but there has never been this kind of
concentration of power.
Well yeah,
but they're not doing anything with the
power that we know of.
What would they do have is tremendous
wealth like off the charts,
tremendous wealth at apple,
at Google.
I mean they just have tremendous amount
of influence and I think when you have
that kind of money,
like idealistic,
hippie leftwing dreamers are way better
off like throwing that money around then
like really gangster globalists that
are,
you know,
pro war,
really enthusiastic about right wing
politics like that will be way scarier
if all that money,
the billions of dollars was in a
Cristiana cult that thought that the
second coming was going to happen in
Jerusalem.
So it was very important to protect
Israel,
which is real.
There's a lot of people in this country
that want to protect Israel because they
think that's where Jesus is pit stop
when it comes back.
Yeah,
you can.
I do worry about.
Yeah,
you should worry about very religious
people.
So with,
with a messianic.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's a real thing today.
So I think like secular tended reason
based techno freaks who I might disagree
with them on some of the most ridiculous
asks a ridiculous aspects of
progressivism.
Like they just go so far off the charts
and it's so common now.
Everyone is getting so hysterical about
things.
You know Christina Hoff sommers is.
I love her.
She's great.
She's got love her.
She's got literally shouted down
offstage.
They interrupted her speech,
they put up signs.
They wouldn't let her talk through.
We're calling her a fascist where they
sound really confident in their point of
view.
Huh?
It's just so pleased.
But they don't engage somebody in ideas
a shout them down because you're
terrified.
Well,
what they're doing also is they're
getting on Youtube.
So there's all these videos of them
being woke.
Hashtag woke expressing their wokeness.
I haven't heard that expression.
I know you have.
Yeah.
You're just talking about it.
Yeah,
it's a gross
word.
I think it comes down to what I was
amazed.
What I'm amazed at is I've talked to
some of these far left ideologues,
you know,
and uh,
and especially the people that would
shout down,
Christine Summers,
who is such a reason voice in such an
important voice to smart and let her
talk and then if you disagree with her,
have a conversation with you.
Are they typically do a q and a at the
end of these speeches that's just rude
to her with your ideas.
And she's a feminist for fucking podcast
is called progress.
Actual feminist.
That's what her,
her thing is her video series that she
does now.
She's an important person,
man.
She's not an anti woman in any way,
shape or form.
She's not the female.
I've listened to her and she,
she wrote that book,
the war on boys.
She's,
she's excellent.
She's excellent.
But I think a lot of this is like,
one of the things I noticed is that a
lot of the left wing idiot logs at that
first of all are fairly young.
A lot of times they don't have a whole
lot of experience in the world or you
know,
they are people who are like,
if you just take the average journalist,
and I've met a lot of them now and talk
to a lot of them,
the average journalist,
even the average academic in colleges or
in the people that are kind of
controlling this conversation in certain
aspects,
they have just not really ever met
anybody or worked with anybody that
worked with their hands that he spends a
lot of time that had to be in the
military that,
um,
they,
they tend to be pretty cloistered,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
even even Sam Harris by his own
admission said that in his Rolodex of
1100 people,
he only had one friend who smoked.
And that was Christopher hitchens.
That significant.
It's significant when you are exposed to
one element of society.
And one of the advantages that I think a
comic has when you travel so much is
that you're around real people.
People that work with their hands,
people to do other things that are in
the military,
people that are cops,
people that are,
that are essentially a huge part of the
fabric of this side who are on the right
on uncertainty on the left.
And what you start to realize is that
your,
um,
the world is way more complicated as is
always the way it is,
right?
It's just way more complicated.
People are way less,
uh,
easy to pigeonhole there.
Just because you supported trump doesn't
necessarily mean you are right winner
across the board.
It doesn't mean you're,
you know,
about the patriarchy and stuff.
And I find that a lot of young people
and I find a lot of people who are
trying to be woke and stuff.
And we do this as Americans.
It's not just the left,
it's also the right.
We do this as Americans.
We want to find a bad guy and we want to
put a label on that bad guy.
We want a single variable answer.
We want a single variable solution,
right?
So in other words,
you are racist,
you are a sexist,
you are a homophobe,
so you've got to be sanctioned and we
got to get rid of you.
And if we can get rid of racism as if
racism has a and do with it.
Actually it's about tribalism because
people don't need a difference in skin
color to hate each other.
Have you heard of the Middle East or
Africa or even this country?
It's not about the melanin in your skin,
it's just we're tribal,
but,
but we tend to want to find that one
label.
You're a racist.
You're a homophobe bibles.
Most certainly racist.
Yeah,
of course there are.
You beat.
Don't think racism is the problem that
we're facing.
I think it's more of a tribalism.
I think that if everybody was the same
color,
we'd have no problem,
uh,
joining groups and hitting each other.
No problem.
Again.
Well,
that's where you see the Middle East,
that's for sure.
Look,
Yuval Harari,
racism is just a symptom of that.
You Bet.
Harare's a great book sapiens and
everybody should read it.
Read it on your recommendation.
If the Dinka,
the Dinka and the Nuer and the Sudan,
let's just take them.
They look exactly the same.
Just Google it.
They have an exact,
just racist,
right?
They like saying all black people have
exactly the same.
Well,
they look,
they do.
Look,
they,
they are basically,
they are,
they are they the only way to tell them
the difference is the tribal markings.
But for the most part they're,
they look exactly the same.
Very similar cultures or hurting
culture.
A Dinka and the Dinka language means
people knew in the new,
uh,
language means original people.
Whoa.
And they're sworn enemies.
They fucking hate each other.
Talk to justin ran about.
Yeah,
Ta Talk to Justin Wren about how the
pygmies are treated in the country right
next door.
They're brutally discriminated.
They can't even go to hospitals or
schools because they're short and
they're magic apparently.
So go fuck yourself.
It ain't about color.
We don't need color to hate each other.
We just don't.
We would find something.
It would be neighborhoods or lines in
the dirt or sports teams.
Fuck yes.
We,
we mean we hate each other from
neighboring high schools in the same
town.
We compete with each other.
Maybe it's a good,
good natured competition.
There's nothing wrong with that either.
There's a natural need that we have to
compete against each other and conquer
each other,
and that's because we used to do that
exclusively,
right?
That's how people move.
That's what this Viking show is all
about.
People coming into peoples' villages,
fucking them up and taken all their gold
and just,
that's what people did forever.
Fuck yes,
and,
but here's the other thing.
It's really taboo.
This is so fucking taboo.
Even say this.
Now what are you going to risk something
so.
So the narrative is those people aren't
doing well.
Let's just take any group of people
they're not doing well,
right?
Because they've been.
There's only one answer to that.
They've been put down.
They been oppressed,
they've been suppressed.
Yes.
Sometimes that's true,
right?
Nobody can tell me you don't understand
the history of this country unless you
studied the black experience at least a
little bit because that is.
That is such a huge part of the history
of this country and to be a black person
in this country is not something I have
no idea about,
but it hasn't been easy.
Granted,
let's just take any ethnic group.
If you were to ever like Thomas Soul,
who's a black scholar,
if you were ever to bring up the idea
that maybe part of the problem in
certain groups,
okay,
that aren't doing well,
could be internal,
could be of their own making,
could be that there are certain aspects
of that person's culture,
whether they're in Hewitt,
whether they're Mexican,
whether they're black or whether they're
a hillbilly white guy.
If you start talking about the fact that
their culture and the way they.
Their belief,
their,
their practices could have something to
do with why they're not getting ahead.
You better be damn careful because now
you're blaming the victim because it is
true that,
well,
you're not really necessarily blaming
the victim,
right?
Because the victim in this case is a
person who's a part of a culture and
we're all influenced by our environment
and if you were involved in a culture
that has very specific ways of behaving
and you're supposed to engage in these
and whether it's a know female genital
mutilation that they do to children on a
regular basis in some parts of the
world,
like why did they do that?
Well,
they've just been doing that.
That's what they've been doing that.
So they just keep doing that.
Like there's a lot of weird things that
people just get sucked into and then you
don't even realize what you're doing.
You're 18.
You live in that life.
Then it becomes a part of your pattern
or behavior and then when you're 35 and
everyone around you is behaving the same
way in the world filled with violence
and no one can hit the pause button and
go,
hey,
why we getting each other,
Hutus and Tutsis like,
what are we doing?
No one's like,
stop,
settle the fuck down.
It's like you get locked up in the
momentum of your past,
of the past,
of your family,
your ancestors,
your community,
your environment.
Very few people have complete autonomy,
so the idea that we're supposed to ask
somebody to just figure it out or get
their shit together,
pull themselves up by their bootstraps.
It's pretty preposterous.
Fuck yeah,
and it's usually coming from people that
got a nice juicy hand like life gave you
a couple of aces and you got to seven
over there and a two and you try to
figure out if you can get a flush,
like you've got a good hand.
You got lucky.
So if you say you made it with a good
hand,
like,
oh,
congratulations.
You won the pot.
You got dealt three aces.
You kinda.
Exactly.
You got lucky.
I'll be the first to admit that should
be the first.
I mean that some people are born with
more advantaged than others.
Just a better family.
Just stop for a moment and I don't want
to get to this are already to Social
Justice Warrior II in this podcast,
but this is one of the things that
pisses me off and said,
I agree with so many of those twats on
so many important issues and then they
get so crazy that they wanted to
interrupt people at Christina Hoff
summers and yell at.
She's a fascist and
we just,
we.
There's just too much conflict.
That doesn't make any sense today.
They're not reasonable that they're not
civil or reasonable,
so I don't know where else to go.
Like what if you're not going to be
reasonable and you're going to decide
that you're that right,
that you
are,
that your site is rooted in truth and
love and that and my sides rooted in
falsehood.
Knievel,
salt,
aggressive issues are all.
It's no,
no one has ever like super into women's
rights but racist,
like they're all like there's a pattern
of behavior that you're supposed to
follow them.
It's like really?
It's a really interesting predetermined
pattern that everybody locks into
because it's support gay marriage.
It's like all these things.
Well,
you can yell.
It's like,
it's like if you're,
if you're in favor,
if you believe that global warming is
caused by human beings,
you've got to be in the right.
You know you,
unless you're.
Unless you know where you stand on gay
marriage,
on everything else like that,
that's unfortunately you can't be sort
of responsive to evidence.
Right?
So instead of being affiliated with a
party or a candidate be affiliated with
the problem,
what's the problem?
Will agree with all three shooters,
right?
That socks.
Yes.
So there's gotta be a way,
if we could put our ideas together,
create a little idea.
Sex.
There's gotta be a way,
right?
There's gotta be a way to deal with this
problem.
Oh,
well,
can we talk about the fact that we all
agree that the problem socks.
Now you're saying we need more guns and
this other side saying we need less
guns.
Is there,
is there something,
is there something we can.
Can we at least start talking instead?
Because you know,
Brendan on the podcast said,
can we agree that a gum problem,
the fucking number of hate emails we got
to know,
want to give up those guns and,
and,
and uh,
yeah.
And,
and Jim Jefferies was so funny because
he goes and his pod.
Did you hear that?
That,
that stand up in it.
He goes,
here's the argument,
because I like them so fuck off.
And it's like,
that's good enough.
Yeah.
The constitution says that guns,
we have a right to bear arms so we can
protect ourselves against tyrannical
government.
Right?
I mean that's,
that's what the second amendment.
Well,
you know,
he's like,
the government has drones,
right?
They got tanks,
they've got cruise missiles.
Your ar 15 ain't doing shit.
Another problem.
This is,
people need to understand this.
The government is us.
Okay.
Everybody that you just described,
someone who works in the military,
everyone just described someone who's a
soldier,
two soldiers or civilians,
they're the same people.
They're people,
they're us.
We're not talking about some global
elites.
It's going to take over.
They're not taking over with us.
We are not going to take over ourselves.
We're not.
This is not a stupid fucking country.
Like the idea that somehow or another
the military will start taking them.
Well,
we have to be careful is people that
have extreme power and shit.
Judgment.
Like that cop that shot that kid in the
hallway in Arizona that that horrible
video was bad white guy shooting a white
guy too.
By the way.
I don't even know if that has anything
to do with racism with a lot of what
cops are doing.
I think some of it most certainly does,
but I think a lot of it has to do with
people to just incompetent and they're
police officers and they shouldn't be
police officers and on top of that,
I think the stress of the job just
breaks people's brains and I think
sometimes people are just so out of
their fucking mind with worrying about
being shot and dealing with trauma and
dealing with violence and dealing with
domestic abuse and fucking murdered kids
and all the fucked up things.
They say.
See everyday they're brains are frazzled
man and they're stepping out into the
street and then they can confront
somebody and they just want to fucking
shoot.
I just want to shoot before they get
shot there on a hair trigger,
man,
that's a couple of seconds to write
sometimes and sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes they plant a gun on the guy.
I mean sometimes it's absolutely a dirty
cop.
Right?
You know,
sometimes the guy's reaching for his
wallet,
they shoot him in the car with his baby
in the backseat.
This has been a bunch of these things,
man,
and I think it boils down to more than
anything,
people that are fucking completely
incompetent at being a police officer.
What's amazing is the number of
interactions where you never hear shit
about.
What's amazing is how many people get
pulled over every day.
How many people deal with a cop,
how many people get questioned by a cop?
How many people are in a situation where
a cop has to talk to them about
something that happened and nothing
happens and nobody gets shot.
It's overwhelming.
The numbers of actual interactions where
everything goes okay,
far outweigh the dirty cop that shoots
the kid in the hallway.
Of course,
the and the,
the,
the cop that plants the Taser and the
guy after he shoots them.
All these different things where there's
a dirty guy,
there's just people.
The number of honorable police officers
is actually pretty fucking stunningly
positive.
So if cops that save lives or stop
crying from happiness and all those
things protect people.
Human beings have this crazy brain right
where this negativity bias where
something like violence and stuff has
such an effect on our brain.
We're really good at seeing problems but
really bad at,
at coming up with the solutions like we
tend to jump to.
So if you,
if there's a problem,
if it's a very.
It's a very thing about terrorism,
right?
If people die on,
it's a very scary situation.
Far More people die of diabetes.
Far More people die of heart disease.
People die if the way you're eating far
more die from all the various
pharmaceutical opiates.
That's exactly right.
I mean,
I can't tell how many people die of of
aspirin,
some crazy number think it's $10,000
crazy,
but things are not as sexy,
but we tend to react to the things that
really scare us.
Right?
Yeah.
We'll violence violence is what gets us
not disease.
Like,
dude,
I know two people who have lost loved
ones to the flu this year.
Yeah.
Yup.
One of them was a 14 year old girl.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
The flu killed Jesus do this.
Flu is no fucking shot for two weeks.
Dude,
it's.
You get a joke.
I got.
I was going down for a couple of days
because I caught it really early on.
I knew it was happening and I did
nothing.
I stayed home and I ate real good and I
just slept all day.
I let my body I worked out.
You can't ask those.
The working out ones are the worst.
Killed me.
I've had that happen before was thinking
I was a little bit sick and then I
worked out and it just gripped me.
Got Me.
I'd never been sick like that.
Hadn't six since college.
I was real proud of myself that I
recognized it.
I was like,
something's going on here.
Like I,
I'm pretty in tune with what I'm feeling
like a pussy.
Well,
I'm just lazy and when like my body just
feels off
and I'm like,
my body feels off.
And then I was like,
oh my God,
I know sweating and I'd be sitting there
with Chili and then I'd be sweating.
And I was like,
okay,
I'm just going to get under the covers
and Netflix the fuck out of these couple
of days because I did that two days ago
where everybody in my family was sick.
They,
everybody's getting cold.
Everybody around was getting cold and I,
I,
it was eight hours.
I'd been sleeping eight hours.
I couldn't get out of bed and I was
like,
I'm tired.
I slept.
Yeah,
fucking slept for 11 hours.
Felt tip top.
My body fought it.
I was like,
I'm not moving until it's the mood has
to get asked to move and you got to have
a healthy body.
Folks.
This is the one thing that I got from
this year and it was only,
like I said,
it was really only fucked up for like
two days,
but one thing that God is how wonderful
it is to be healthy.
Yeah.
I mean we take this fucking thing for
granted.
This vitality you take just feeling
good.
Like right now,
right now.
Right now I feel great.
I feel great.
Yeah,
me too.
Ate Breakfast at,
worked out.
I'm healthy.
Hanging out with my friend.
Yeah.
There are podcasts.
There are two things they talk about
like when you do a to a country.
Number one is this,
this fucking behavioral scientist named.
He wrote a book called scarcity and his
name is uh,
lr chef here and I did a podcast with
him and he'd studies like how humans
behave when they have.
They don't have enough food in their
stomach,
like most economists wrote their
treatises from a full stomach.
Adam Smith,
the father of capitalism was also living
with his mother when he wrote the moral
sentiments of man and the wealth of
nations.
Okay.
So,
and so he was,
what,
what you don't hear as,
as this,
this company.
Uh,
so he was like,
well,
the Internet Marketing Gurus,
and I was like,
Ferrari's that he rented this mom's
driveway.
Well,
you know,
this,
this woman,
I was talking about the free market and
I'm a free market guy and you know,
I'm a capitalist.
And she said,
that's great.
And I've been inundated in the sort of
the extreme Milton Friedman Faa High
School of Economics.
But she was like,
she had a thing called doughnut
economics and she's out of Oxford and
Kate Rayburn.
And she,
she said,
well,
you know,
what they don't tell you is when Adam
Smith was writing the wealth of nations,
the fucking handbook for all capitalist
and free market guys like yourself is
that his mother was like,
Adam,
dinner's almost ready.
And uh,
I,
uh,
I folded your laundry,
you know,
what's that worth?
What the fuck is that?
You know what I mean?
So you got to take those things into
account.
So funny,
my,
My,
my perspective on,
on capitalism has always come from a
full belly.
Never been hungry.
I was a wrestler guys.
I did have to suck a lot of weight.
The point is never been hungry.
Never had to worry about where my next
meal was coming from.
Certainly never had to worry about a
roof over my head.
That's a.
that's a big difference between even a
guy like me and you like this.
You got your.
Your perspective is going to be
different.
It's going to be adult has to be.
There's a level of compassion.
I think that as a civilization we
haven't hit.
We haven't hit the right number.
We're in this number where we.
We don't give a fuck about each other
enough and I think that one of the ways
that that could be solved is I've been
thinking a lot about universal basis,
basic income that
if that was a possibility where you
could give everybody just a small amount
of money,
like $12,000
a year,
which is like a thousand dollars a
month.
It's basically enough to get by,
but you wouldn't have to think about
that.
Then you wouldn't have to think about
that aspect.
Like you would always have food.
If we could make sure that everybody
always had food and everybody always had
a place to sleep,
what would that cost?
What would it cost to eradicate
homelessness to a point where if you
were homeless,
it was a total voluntary situation.
Either you're just a nomad who likes
camping or you're.
You're mentally ill and you just need to
sleep in a box because you think that's
the only way that the aliens can't get
you.
There's,
there's those people at skid row is
filled with crazy.
Crazy.
How much,
how like what percentage of our cities
have homeless people in them?
Like is it three percent of the city's
homeless?
One percent of the city's almost summer
climates.
It's higher,
right?
How would,
how,
how much of an impact would it be if you
could just bring that down to zero?
I mean,
wouldn't that be just great for the way
people feel about other people?
Well,
there are societies that do that.
Singapore,
certain Scandinavian,
very hippie.
This podcast is a strong weed.
Well,
no,
I mean,
but you're at.
You're asking a really good question
because they have done these
experiments.
Twenty billion.
That's it.
They,
they could end homeless,
sorry,
sorry.
With money used to buy Christmas
decorations,
it would cost about $20 million for the
government to effectively eliminate
homelessness in the United States of
housing and urban development official
told the New York Times Monday,
December 11,
2012.
So I think for what we spend it,
it's kind of the wrong question because
I give a man a fish or feed them in and
teach a man to fish.
It's a really tricky.
It is.
They have to be careful.
It's a weird question,
but it's also one that no one's
addressing.
It's like I,
you look at people who are homeless to
go,
Oh,
you fucking bomb,
get your shit together.
All you lazy.
Fuck or all you crazy person.
Oh,
he must be a junkie.
You know,
so,
so can I tell you,
so my friend works for does this worse
with homeless youth and uh,
I'm pretty extensively.
Hasn't done it for 20 years and actually
the what he'll tell you and he's very
compassionate person,
but he'll tell you that the system in
this city of Los Angeles,
there are a lot of resources for people
on the street from places to get a
computer,
places to sleep,
places to take a shower there and and
what happens is there are a lot of
people that get this network.
They figure out where to go and one of
the things that they are talking about
in this community and trying to get kids
and homeless people off the street.
It's one,
one thing.
There are a lot.
It's a complicated issue,
but what has been said and it was
shocking to me was they were like,
problem is the system is so easy to
game.
It's so easy to.
You can live on the street and
live.
You can.
You can,
when you're a youth,
you can actually,
if you understand how to how to work the
system.
There are so many resources that a lot
of times it doesn't lend itself to
really needing to get out of a situation
right now,
but how many of these kids are playing
this out like this with a gaming the
system?
A lot of really because you're a human
being,
so you figure out where you can get your
breakfast,
where you can get a shower,
where you can get your computer,
where you can get your hangout,
where you can get all these things
somehow under that's hurting them.
I'm not saying,
look,
I'm not saying we shouldn't have these
resources.
Right?
I thought it was fascinating that a lot
of the people that are really on the
front lines and all in this are saying
that the the ironic and frustrating
thing sometimes can be that it does
create not complacency,
but certainly there are way more
resources than you think.
There are people that have worked very
hard to address this problem and people
do it when they know where to go.
They do know where to get food.
They do know where to get a shower.
They do know what to do so they can live
on the street.
There's.
There's many levels to this.
Right?
First of all,
one of the big levels,
the inescapable is mental illness.
Yeah.
Those people.
There's a lot of people that are
wandering around the street that really
should probably be in some sort of an
institution.
Yes.
Getting healthcare.
Yes and medicated.
Yes.
But how do you force someone to do that
and is it that,
is that the issue or is it a funding
issue?
You know,
that was an issue apparently.
Putting Reagan.
Yeah.
When Reagan was in office,
they lower the standard of what's Cuckoo
for cocoa puffs and they just let a
bunch of dudes just wander through the
street.
That actually wasn't the.
It was a little bit more complicated
than that.
It was.
It was at the state doesn't have a right
to keep you against your will if you
don't want to be.
Right.
So.
So there had to be very specific
criteria for that.
So you know,
this whole thing with gun control,
like we need to help mental health
issue.
Well,
there's,
if you talked to the psychiatrist will
be like,
look dude,
the criteria for getting tougher,
saying,
saying and getting somebody essentially
classified as a danger to society and
uh,
like a real threat is very steep.
It's hard to do.
Yeah,
you,
you can't do that because somebody talks
to themselves.
You can't do it because they're hearing
voices.
Well,
the other doesn't want to visit that kid
two years ago,
right?
The kid who shot up to school in Florida
and they decided he wasn't a threat,
but he might not have been a threat to
years ago.
Like people saying,
Oh,
you know,
they visited them two years ago.
They're incompetent.
No,
he might be a different person now you
have to realize that like people get way
worse.
Like we've all known people that we knew
at one point in time in your life,
then you don't see him for six years and
then you see them,
you're like,
whoa,
well that's because people evolve and
sometimes they evolve and sometimes they
don't.
Sometimes they recede.
Sometimes it gets ugly.
So definitely didn't you go crazy?
Aren't you talking about how because 20
percent of boys in this fucking country,
r,
d,
a r,
r,
a diagnosed with Adhd,
diagnosed of course because you haven't
spent 10 minutes with you who's not an
expert on Adhd.
It could be a thousand other things.
I just.
We have a boy.
It was on Rhonda.
Patrick
posted up to study and then we're
lugging a d hd was something that was
not the one that was created.
See if Google this too.
Sorry.
Adhd was the one that was created by the
advertising agency.
What a surprise.
There's been several conditions that
were literally invented by advertising
agencies in order to promote a cure,
so it's attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder.
Yeah.
Look,
I don't know how much of that is a real
disease and maybe maybe some of it is.
Maybe I'm not.
I'm obviously not an expert.
Maybe some of it is a kid whose brain
works different.
Right.
Let me tell you something,
man.
My dog might have adhd or whatever the
fuck it is.
I go to see him and he goes crazy.
He's.
He's out of his fucking mind.
He thinks we're going running,
he's running around in circles,
he's hopping up and down.
He bolts back and forth into the
backyard.
He's like a maniac,
like I can't control them.
You know what the solution for that is?
I take him running,
right?
I don't lock them in a room and then
drug them.
You know what I was wanting to dealing
with little kid.
You know when I was really focused.
You know what?
I wasn't focused Algebra.
I was really focused.
If somebody started talking about
fighting and how to throw a right hand,
just think about what I'm saying with my
dog.
I mean there's really something to that.
Like that dog wanted to go run and
invite you to forced him to sit into a
room.
He would go crazy bark and he wouldn't
want to do that.
That's how kids are exactly the same
goddamn thing.
There it is.
Yeah.
The drugging of the American boy.
But what was the tweet?
Jamie?
Is this an esquire article?
What did it.
What did the tweet say?
One in five boys will be diagnosed with
Adhd by the time they make it to high
school to date.
Only one significant study has looked at
adhd misdiagnosis and found 20 to 25
percent of boys were misdiagnosed and
this was before a d,
h,
d was a ca as common as it is now,
so they're saying it's a real issue.
I know quite a few people that are
drugging their kids.
This is my next door neighbor.
They put their fucking kid on Ritalin.
There was nothing wrong with this kid.
I talked to that kid all the times.
It just takes too much energy that you
just had too much energy and they didn't
want to deal with it and they weren't
paying attention to them.
They worked all day and then the kids
bouncing off the walls and nobody wants
to take care of the kid and so they put
him on Ritalin.
Awful dude,
it's happening everywhere.
It's happening.
The bad side effects some of these
drugs.
Look at this,
six point 4 million children between the
ages of four and 17 have been diagnosed
with Adhd by high school.
Nearly 20 percent of all boys will have
been diagnosed with Adhd.
A 37 percent,
37 percent increase since 2003.
My son,
my son is a classic example of a kid who
doesn't like to sit still and rough
houses.
Google does have adhd,
so if a school's have no time for horse,
they have no time for boy energy.
No,
you're.
You're.
You're condemned because it's aggressive
and my son is the way to not be a boy.
He's being told that his hands are hot
lava and he can't use his hands.
That's healthy.
Oh my God.
What kind of liberal school you've taken
for public school?
Public School.
That's what happens.
That's awful.
This is what we're dealing with.
A 1900 adhd was first mentioned in 19.
Oh,
two British pediatric pediatrician.
So it must be a wrong one.
A different one described an abnormal
defect of moral control and children.
He found that some effective children
could not control behavior the way a
typical child would,
but they were still intelligent.
Maybe it was restless legs syndrome.
Was that.
Didn't you tell me that one might have
been,
but I don't know.
Who was the.
Who was the guest?
Do you remember?
The guest was a woman who was telling us
all about this.
Some medical expert.
Was it Kelly Brogan?
It might've been.
Might've been Kelly Brogan.
Dr Kelly,
but what didn't you say weren't.
Aren't there studies about school
shooters and a lot of them were on SSR.
I's and stuff.
Yes.
Mass shooters.
Not just school shooters,
but like even this Vegas Guy,
the Vegas guy was on anti anxiety
medication.
Yeah,
that stuff in.
That's also Chris Cornell was on anti
anxiety medication.
There is a lot of people who are on
psych drugs who lose their fucking minds
because psych drugs are not universal.
Right?
Like there's no thing like here's a
perfect example.
Say if you have a.
There is a solution that makes alcohol
91 octane.
Right.
And you add something to that and you
can add some additives and it'll spike
it up and you could try to find the
right mixture,
but that's just fucking gasoline.
You throwing things in there and try to
mix it up.
You don't know exactly what the right
thing is.
That's how they're doing your brain.
Correct.
When the chipkey these things,
that's why they say,
try this one.
There's not like,
okay,
you have one cup of flour,
you need two eggs and one tablespoon of
sugar.
No,
no,
no.
There's no specific recipe.
And what the fuck does feel good mean
that the other thing that they're not
taking into account is said,
you know,
you might be depressed for a good
reason.
In other words,
if you made me do a job I hated and,
and I wasn't allowed to work out or I
didn't know how to eat or a thousand
things.
They make me feel good because I have to
self regulate.
Yes.
I'm 51 and I gotta I gotta I still have
to self regulate because otherwise,
um,
you know,
I'll go crazy if I don't have.
If I didn't know how to do those things,
I would probably be depressed now.
Now you're going to give me drugs.
Well that's not going to help me.
Well,
here's what it is.
What I'm doing.
My behavior is what it is.
For sure,
but here's where I think you've got to
recognize that that kid,
your son who has that energy,
that's a gift and what you're doing is
you're making them squander that gift by
sitting them down in a fucking charity,
wants to go crazy.
That kid is supposed to be like my dog
running around all day.
Okay?
My dog is a year old at seven.
He's a seven year old dog basically,
you know,
in dog years and he's like a seven year
old kid.
He's running around,
he's going fucking crazy,
you know,
but that's because he wants to run.
Exactly.
But once he runs,
he's high dogs the best.
Yes.
And your kid will be to,
if you,
if your kid was involved in something
where they emphasized physical movement
and then taught things in between
workouts,
taught things in between,
you know,
they play a game outside,
play a little dodge ball,
play a little soccer,
play a little basketball.
Then after you wear yourself out a
little,
come sit down.
We're going to teach about math.
Teach them about math and then you know
you're going to show them,
this is leverage.
We're all going to pick things up.
Can you think you'd pick it up like or
like let them now pick it up with
leverage.
Oh,
you see,
you understand you could teach kids in a
very physical way instead of forcing
them to sit down.
Who the fuck wants to sit that hard ass
chair?
We feel other people's gum on the top of
your leg.
You know,
it sucks.
It sucks.
You're sitting there waiting for the
fucking class to be over stuck.
Don't get it.
Their energies.
How did I ever tell you that?
My acting teacher who looked at me time
is the greatest.
And he goes,
uh,
I had done a scene.
He goes,
you know,
we got it with you.
Get a little self esteem problem.
You think of yourself as a second
banana.
And I was like,
what?
He goes,
yeah,
you got to start believing in yourself
more.
He goes,
you got to start thinking of yourself as
a first banana.
Did he say this when he was in his
underwear?
He did.
He was,
I was wearing,
I was wearing black place on it.
He was put these black lace on Nissan.
Hey God,
I'm going to pierce her nipples.
Know this.
What's that?
Why?
Why do you smell a Cologne that persil
this is weird.
So he,
he says that to me and I'm a young actor
and I'm fucked up of her and I'm like,
I got to get better.
I got to get a higher self esteem.
So I say to my buddies,
kind of group of guys,
one of my buddy's older and wiser and I
said,
man,
I,
I was told I have low self esteem,
you know,
and I heard fortunate back over there
goes,
thank God you really think you'd be this
funny if you fucking like yourself bro,
and you think you'd be a fucking actor
if you liked yourself,
go fuck yourself.
That guy's an asshole.
Keep hating yourself.
It's the best part of you.
That's how that got tanks.
Monk.
I know.
I was like,
you're right.
I liked it.
The whole point,
that whole thing that drives me is the
fact that I've never been satisfied with
myself and I'm never going to lose that.
I,
if I,
if you make me really happy with myself,
I'm not so sure it's a good thing.
You know what?
You got to figure out how to do,
I think not you,
but I think humans to somehow or another
disconnect you from the result.
If you could figure out a way to
disconnect you from the result,
you could look at it more objectively.
You're going to feel the sting of
failure.
It's a fact,
but you have to recognize what that is
and intellectualize it.
You got to put it in this little box.
Okay,
this is good because now I'm going to be
fucking pumped up to improve.
I'm going to recognize the urgency and
failure because it's so extremely
uncomfortable,
but that's not me.
What me is,
is the person who's doing this and I'm
eventually going to be a finished
product.
I'm going to figure this out,
but right now,
that little thing that happened that
sucks.
Like,
okay,
don't freak out you.
Everybody fucks up.
Maybe you fucked up this way,
but you didn't run into someone's car.
Maybe you did run into someone's car,
but you didn't do this.
Everybody's got their own little fuck
failure,
a huge part of part of being a human.
You got to understand the consequences
of doing something incorrectly.
The end,
especially the humiliating feeling of
being like put in your place like you
might think you're good at something and
then you fail at it.
You Go,
oh my God,
I got this elevated sense of how good I
was at this thing.
Now I have to look at it more
objectively and I have to get to that
place where I thought I was just.
People don't want to wear Andy Kalpin.
Have you had great very smart guy,
brilliant guy.
I said,
what's best for recovery?
And he goes,
why do you want to recover?
That's what do you mean?
He goes,
well,
why don't you let your body adapt and
figure it out.
Just eat some food,
see how it feels,
but maybe maybe suffer a little bit and
see what that does because your body
might have to compensate and get
stronger as a result.
Sure.
An interesting way of looking at it,
I was like,
I think there's definitely something to
that.
I mean,
I think that's why people push,
right?
That's what pushing is.
It's forcing adaptation.
You're,
your body's going,
oh my God,
this asshole wants to dead lift now.
Right?
Okay,
I've got to,
I've got to adapt.
Now.
That's also with the sauna is you got
to.
Your body's trying to adapt.
Okay,
this asshole wants to live at 170
degrees.
I have to figure out how to keep
everything from shutting down.
Let's mass produce these heat shock
proteins and try to figure out,
you know,
how norepinephrine,
it's also like being honest with
somebody is right.
So like it's also kinda like sitting and
hearing things.
You don't want to hear about yourself.
Maybe shortcomings,
right?
So when somebody says some somebody
something to you,
like you're not taking yourself,
you're not working hard enough or you're
not working correctly or you did this
wrong,
or your ideas are a bit bankrupt.
Let me tell you why that shit is not fun
at all here.
But it's exactly like working out.
If you could just sit and listen and
take it in,
not argue it.
Listen,
take it in,
feel bad.
For Awhile,
I promise you,
I promise you that that's probably the
best way to change listening and hearing
it because it'll bother you,
let it bother you and then let that
spurned you to action.
If you,
if you,
if you want to get,
if you want to shout Christina summers
down or you want to get into your safe
space and not hear those things because
they hurt you,
this is why they're.
Yeah,
but that's only part of the problem.
The real problem is a control power
problem.
The country,
there's control and power problems
because these are 18 year old kids and
they've just gotten away from home for
the first time and they want to exercise
their power and they want to change the
world and they're fucking babies.
They have half baked brains and they
want to yell shit out and they think
that they're doing the right thing.
They really do and they were yelling
outside.
You can't have.
We won't have fascists in our school.
You see Jordan Peterson was doing a
speech and they were literally at the
windows.
They climb the walls and got to the
windows,
were banging on the windows from the
outside while the speech went on.
Wow Dude.
It's disturbing.
And everyone inside his super calm and
there's people that keep an eye on the
window because you hear it cracking.
So like there's a smashing this fucking
window just banging up against it.
The entire time he's talking,
he just hear Bang,
Bang,
Bang.
And they're yelling shit outside about
fascism or it's like they don't even
know what the fuck that means.
Like they literally are just saying it
for anybody who disagrees with them.
When a real fascist comes along,
they're going to be so duped.
There'll be,
there'll be shot against a wall and
shot.
That's what,
that's what fascists do real fast.
But they seem to think that disagreeing
with,
uh,
people were out of their fucking mind.
They don't have any quotes fascism,
they,
but they have no confidence.
Right?
So,
so.
Well,
because if you're having an argument
with somebody and you end up hitting
them because they're saying because you
don't like it means you don't have.
The idea is to compete with their ideas.
You know,
I don't think it's that dude.
I think they're just young and they
don't understand what the fuck they're
doing.
They're,
they're,
they're enjoying this ability to scream
out.
It's like I said,
practicing.
Yeah.
Have got way too much power.
Their children.
Yeah.
They're essentially children.
They could go to war,
some of them and yeah,
they can,
but that's not right.
Anyway.
They probably shouldn't be able to.
Probably like 21 before you make that
decision.
The whole thing's fucking crazy.
It's crazy that they don't have enough
security to keep the fucking kids are
banging on the windows.
Like what kind of nonsense facility do
you run?
You just didn't see that comment.
Are you guys,
do you have the Internet?
You guys have the Internet.
It's kind of see what's going on.
As kind of knew the American culture has
always been a few years.
Know what I'm saying?
American culture has always given like
their kids.
Is that recently too.
I mean,
Jonathan,
I had talks about this like helicopter
parenting and sort of the idea that your
kid has his own autonomy and it's very
important.
I,
I've,
I've seen all the new science on this.
I mean for sure.
Yeah,
definitely.
Your kid has ticks,
is allowed to exercise their point of
view and have a tantrum and then you
have to show them that,
that,
that there are consequences for that and
that's a new way of looking at,
you know,
a lot of cultures are like,
Hey,
if you fucking talk to me like that
again,
I'm going to hit you in the fucking.
I'm going to take this riding crop and
whack your fucking legs or whatever it
might be.
So I don't know.
Well,
we've got a real soft right now.
It's a real easy time to be alive and I
think ultimately the ship's going to
balance out a really do.
And I think ultimately a lot of these
kids that are super radical now will
probably stabilize as they get older and
more experienced,
would be more embarrassed with some of
the things they've done to especially to
disrupt free speech.
They they should really be embarrassed
by that because it's so foolish like
you.
All you have to do is formulate a really
good argument with ideas and then you
play those ideas out in the court of
public opinion.
You do it in some sort of a way where
you have a one person representing one
side,
one person representing the other side,
and you beat that idea with better ideas
and that's what you're supposed to do.
That's the whole exercise and these
people that oppose your ideas.
You should use that to challenge you to
improve your ideas,
to make your,
improve your ideas undeniable so that
when you present that argument,
you've looked at it from both sides.
There's far too many people,
including these people that are
interrupting people that are only
looking at an argument from the point of
view that they would like to be correct
and they're only looking at it like
she's a fashion.
She's a Nazi.
They're not looking at real,
hey,
maybe that's just a lady and maybe she's
a nice lady and maybe she's got some
points and maybe I agree with her and
maybe I don't,
but you've got to let her talk like this
is all nonsense.
Holding signs up and trying to get
attention.
This is not the time for that.
It doesn't persuade anybody over to your
side.
I'll tell you that much.
They don't even try to do that and
they're just trying to recruit the
troops and then the also the trying to
send out a flag that they care and
they're out here doing the right God
damn thing using my voice.
I'm out here using my voice like it's
like,
no,
you're being a little kid that's
interrupting their tribe and its ways
you're going to be against something.
Then to define what they're for.
If you ever asked them what their for
like I had this conversation quality
bro.
Was that equality where everything,
they don't know what that.
Including comedians.
I want an equal number.
Yeah.
You see what that one Bert?
When someone wants to medians men and
women,
it's the dumbest Shit I've ever heard in
my life.
Are you funny enough to be on the stage?
Okay.
Then I don't give a fuck what you look
like.
I don't care if you're.
Nobody wants to hear that.
Yeah.
Remember when Jerry Seinfeld got in
trouble because they were like,
why's comedian cars having coffee?
All white guys.
Well I dunno,
but you know there are a lot of funny
white guys,
so fuck off.
Funny Black guys too.
Well that's what Jerry Seinfeld studies.
So essentially I don't care what color
they are.
I speak the language of comedy or funny.
Exactly.
And they were like,
that sounds racist.
Sorry,
but that sounds racist.
You're dumb and you're fucking dumb.
What would you say if you were there?
And that lady said that because there
was a woman,
two guys are sitting in a guy and a girl
sitting there talking and they played
the Jerry Seinfeld clip and then the
woman who was an African American was
like,
I'm sorry,
but that's racist.
And I was sitting at home by comic in
the world and most of his audiences that
most of his ticket pairs are white.
He's undeniable that most of the people
that go to his movies are white and he
and he,
he turned it because he's fucking
hilarious.
Right.
But that doesn't have anything to do
with what she,
what she saying is that he's racist
because he's not having black people on
his show.
I don't know how.
But he.
And he's saying,
no,
I don't even care.
I just care.
Are they funny?
I don't care.
Like diversity doesn't mean anything to
me.
I don't care.
And she's like,
that's so racist.
But I feel like when you say something's
racist today,
you don't have to back it up anymore.
I agree.
People just back off.
Especially if you're saying a white
person is racist.
If you say a white person's racist,
everybody pulls out the microphone
though.
My magnifying glass.
Wait a minute,
what have we got here?
We're looking at a waste.
But they'll also say,
you don't even know it.
You don't.
You don't even know it.
Like you're,
you're the white supremacy is everywhere
and will they teach that at schools now?
So now they teach that also at some jobs
you have to go to bias training.
Yeah.
Bias.
Conscious bias training.
What do they call it?
I think it's antibiotic conscious
subconscious bias training.
Like you might even realize you're
racist and you are racist.
How many black guys got in late?
Because of all this
though?
Hopefully a lot.
A lot of hippie white chicks just want
to show they're not racist.
Oh,
that just got it out of his dick down.
Amy.
It's just,
it's,
I'm in the choir jerking off.
What's in crying?
It's just weird,
man.
It's just.
I never,
I've never seen us so divided and part
of it has to do with trump for sure.
There's like this reaction like that.
They feel like I'm really obligated to
act.
People feel obligated to act and try to
make things change,
which I think is ultimately good.
All this thing,
the all what's going on right now does
not concern me nearly as much as it does
a lot of other people because I feel
like people are already reacting to it
and already going,
what in the fuck you know,
and,
and the ship is already starting to
write itself.
Well,
the Oscars was the lowest rated I think
in the history of the Oscar heard that,
but it's also a 26 million people
watched.
That's a lot of fucking people.
That's a lot.
Don't Shit on someone who got 26 million
people were afraid to be.
People get very kind of like,
wow,
we're getting political here.
And when they looked at the numbers,
the numbers where they were comparing it
to like 2013,
there were down $5 million from 2013,
I think it was.
Guess what was it around 2013 Netflix.
True.
There's a lot more shit to watch.
What's it down from last year?
There's definitely people that are bored
with Hollywood though,
like enough.
Well,
they Hollywood's overreach.
I think Hollywood tends to be what
bothers me about Hollywood is there
virtuous virtue signaling,
like they're going to set an example you
fucking guys like you want to be liked.
Okay.
And you're as fickle as it gets.
They were the same people that were
standing up and clapping for Roman
Polanski.
I'm sorry man.
Well,
some of them were.
Some of them were really saying some
ridiculous shit.
I mean,
come on guys.
It's a long time ago and he's drugged
and sodomized at 13 year old.
I think he was like more than one too.
Yeah.
So,
so guess what?
I can't have that guy.
You're not kidding.
They wanted to sign a petition to bring
them back in the country.
I,
I can't forgive that.
No.
Stay in France.
Well,
they want to bring it back to the
country to arrest them and they're
really trying hard to do that.
And there's people that resist that.
I think he's an amazing artist and you
know,
artists are just be consistent though.
You can't system.
That's where I draw the line.
You can't drug kids.
Fuck with Asia Argento,
who was one of the,
one of the people that came out against
Harvey Weinstein,
she had been raped by him apparently,
and then she had a sexual relationship
for 10 years afterwards,
which by the way,
people like,
ah,
that I actually forgive that because
people go back to the trauma,
right?
They want to relive it on their own
terms,
but she signed the petition to for,
for Roman Polanski to,
you know,
to be freed when he was put under arrest
and I believe it was Switzerland and now
that's not consistent.
I'm sorry man,
I'm sorry.
But if that guy is just as bad as,
yeah,
you can see the petition online.
What was her perspective?
She was somebody who thought Roman
Polanski should not be prosecuted for
something that happened a long time ago.
She signed that petition.
I would never sign that petition.
So there's a lot of disconnect.
So I have a big problem with that sort
of disconnect.
That's a problem.
I don't know this woman,
I don't know her.
Um,
I,
I believe,
I believe what she says about Harvey
Weinstein.
Uh,
and again,
you know,
people are like,
well she went back to the scene of the
crime that's very common,
but don't sign a petition and then now
be this leading voice in this whole,
you know,
anti harassment.
I think it's very inconsistent.
I think you have to pay,
you have to at least answer to that.
Did she comment on once she saw there
was a mia culpa there,
but it's very inconsistent in it and
there's a lot of that out there.
There's a lot of that we should make
sure that she definitely did that.
You'll see it.
Just see if you can go the young dreamy.
It feels like something that,
you know,
I looked it up,
I actually looked it up.
I wanted to see who had signed the
petition.
I came across her name and I was like,
whoa.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
You know,
it just doesn't make any sense,
man.
I don't get it.
I don't know enough about what happened.
I know that he drugged in some younger
girl.
She was 13 and her mom dropped her off.
I believe it was there.
It was the seventies men,
people would just relationship every bit
of 20,
all that shit the year.
Um,
man,
but I believe he knew she was 13.
Then he knew he was going to go away to
jail and he left the country to Jesus
Christ and say.
And then apparently there's another
woman that he had done that too.
So imagine being on the scene back then.
How weird that must have been.
Like there had been like think about
Roman Polanski,
making movies and like what the 19
seventies,
right?
Yeah.
I mean God trying to town.
It's only only days.
Yeah.
Amazing.
But they'd only been making movies for
like a few decades.
It was a real new thing.
She signed the petition,
but I found a tweet she just put,
she put out a couple months ago where
she said she regretted doing it.
Already.
Regretted the signing the petition years
ago.
She said a mistake robin plants.
He's a filmmaker whose work at meijer
greatly,
but if I ever see him,
I'll spit in his face if he's lucky.
Yeah.
But you signed petition already.
Regretted signing the petition years ago
already felt it was a mistake.
No excuses.
It was stupid with this indicates a
pattern of behavior that if true and I
believe it to be true is beyond
unforgivable.
Well,
I think,
I think you,
you got a good point though about you.
She made a mistake in there is something
that happens to people that have been
violated.
Sometimes they blame themselves.
That's what I said.
So I'm paying for that and there could
be a little of that in her decision
making process to.
I can't.
I could be a little bit of wanting to be
in with Hollywood,
you know,
that's not ethically or morally
consistent.
No.
And she fucked up and she realized she
fucked up.
But you're also coming after people now,
you know,
if we're gonna,
if we,
we're going to end and a lot of these
people you know,
deserve to become after.
But you know,
we have to be consistent here.
Right?
But isn't she begins being consistent by
just saying that she fucked up and she
realized that she fucked up.
Well,
there are a lot of people are saying
that once they get caught,
well that petition the petition doesn't
mean Jack Shit.
They ain't letting him.
He doesn't matter.
He signed it and it was at.
I don't know anybody that would sign
that and like I would never sign that
petition.
That's all I'm trying to say.
Being consistent if I'm.
So if the guy came to America and got
arrested and went through the trial and
then got convicted,
how much time would you do?
I don't know.
What's interesting is like would it be
better karmically to go to jail for what
he did come back,
go to jail and then no one.
Everyone would always know.
When you got out that you were convicted
and you were punished for child
molestation,
like you did it and they got you.
Everyone would know.
Whereas now he's living in France and he
has to deal with it floating over his
head.
Everyone who meets me knows that I
drugged and raped a kid everywhere I go.
Everyone knows a drugged and raped a kid
and it just keeps playing out in his
head all day long.
Public shaming is powerful shit.
Well,
I mean that's the highest level.
Yes,
this is drugging and raping a kid.
I'm a forgiving guy.
Can't figure that one.
I.
I can't like.
I'm a forgiving dude,
man.
I can't stay mad and I think it's good
to be forgiving about things.
There are certain things that to me when
you,
and he's a great filmmaker and a great
artist for me,
that kind of stuff.
It's very difficult,
man.
It's very difficult.
I had an argument with a bunch of older
actors about this and they were all
saying it was a long time ago.
She looked up and I was like,
if it was your daughter and she was 13,
how would you feel?
You just got to keep going back to that.
Well,
especially if you actually have a
daughter,
you actually have a daughter that's not.
You're not conceptualizing that your
gut.
It actually locked into your brain.
You're actually thinking about your
daughter and it becomes a different
completely different thing.
I remember thinking when I was young,
you know?
Yeah.
If someone did that to my daughter,
but then it was like before I had a kid,
it was like,
that was just a weird concept that
didn't seem real.
But now you think about this 13 year old
girl and you're like,
whoa.
But what a court would do and what a
trial would do is you might hear
something like,
I don't know,
but you might hear.
I don't know.
She said,
she said she was 20.
When we talk about drugging,
hold on.
She smoked a little weed that,
that guy gave her over there.
Let's be careful.
Right then.
Then you start hearing all the
extenuating circumstances and maybe you
would go,
you got to do the time,
but at least I get how that happened
because you thought it was something
different.
Right?
What was your intention?
What did you see?
But we don't know that.
So what happens is we start and we're
doing this too,
and I'm doing it.
I don't know.
I don't know all the details of the
case.
So.
And all I'm saying is that he drugged
and sodomized a 13 year old.
Here's goal that everyone
was drugged,
him included.
Well,
there's this what I'm saying,
so we all have to be,
we all have to be careful and I have to
two,
because I'm,
I'm kind of breaking my own rule here.
I'm,
I'm drawing these very strong,
hardened fast,
uh,
like there's no context and what I'm
saying,
there's no nuance in what I'm saying.
There's no context.
Right?
And you got to be careful because
everything is nuanced and context in a
way otherwise otherwise you.
Otherwise you're taking me at just the
words I'm saying.
So what I'm seeing from this,
this is like she's upset and you're
upset.
Like she's upset.
She signed it and Europe said she signed
it.
But that doesn't mean nearly as much to
me.
Like people making a mistake like her
making that mistake doesn't mean much to
me.
It's just a mistake.
It doesn't give it.
I'm not going to have the thing,
you know,
there's,
there's no consequences.
No one got hurt because of that mistake.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it was a mistake.
She fucked up,
but it didn't ultimately hurt anyone.
Like it doesn't.
I don't like the fact that someone would
at least temporarily have that thought
in their mind like,
that guy should be free,
like leave him alone.
What's bygones be bygones.
Actually talking about something
different.
What are you talking about?
So I'm talking about.dot
Hollywood tends to do.
I was just using her as an example.
Hollywood tends to do that which is
popular,
that which is going to make them liked
rather than something that's morally or
ethically consistent.
That's what I mean.
We've talked about this before,
that it all comes down to the whole
process of being chosen to do things
with being chosen to direct or chosen to
act or chosen.
Everybody's constantly working to be
chosen.
You're all trying to audition for
things.
We're trying to angle to get a certain
role.
It's a constant process of like me,
like me,
like me and these are people that go
into this job with his yearning,
desire to be loved and then on top of
that they're playing this weird
political game.
I mean,
acting is all political.
it doesn't make any sense that every
other occupation except maybe tech
tech's probably like mostly mostly
liberal,
but Hollywood is almost exclusively
liberal and if you step out of those
lines,
nobody wants to work with you anyway.
Hollywood on the surface is liberal,
but actually nobody who's conservative
or whatever will speak out.
Right.
Like Tim Allen lost his show because
he's.
Because he's conservative.
He's an old white guy.
What are you expect?
Well,
white guys.
Yeah,
that's apparently golf.
Probably a very real thing nowadays.
I started hanging out with Dennis
Miller.
Same thing.
He went fucking James.
James Woods is crazy.
James Woods is arguing with people on
twitter.
Like James,
you're 70 years old.
Crazy.
How many days you got left?
How many?
How many moments in your life do you
really have left?
Do you have a thousand?
Like,
what are you going to do?
You're gonna waste.
400 of them on twitter.
Yeah.
That's not wise.
That's not a wise lady.
Said he was blackballed for his
conservative views.
What is he really?
I don't know.
Yeah,
I don't know man.
I don't want to.
Again,
I don't want to be,
um,
I don't know if I'm being helpful.
Right?
So.
Well,
so you know,
you call out certain people.
Are you talking about the inconsistency
is most people are doing the best they
can and trying to make the world a
better place.
Right?
So I think most people would just look
rolling downhill in a hamster wheel.
He thinks,
I'm trying to figure out how to stop
this fucking thing.
Yeah.
Most people are just on full on
momentum.
Most people are definitely not thinking
about how to be,
make the world a better place.
Occasionally people think of that.
What they try to think is how do I get
buy number one?
Then how do I get better?
How do I get ahead?
Number two,
those are the things they think of and
occasionally what's going on?
What's up it over there?
Yeah.
Fucking trump.
And then they go back to work until you
can do sometimes.
Yeah.
Most people,
that's most people like James Woods.
It's like Jesus James,
I get it,
but you're not changing hearts and minds
on twitter.
While the funny shit though sometimes I
was going to say like funny guy,
the biggest thing is like,
you know,
are you,
it's really hard to persuade anybody.
It's fucking like I was thinking about
why would the times I've changed my mind
hard to change my mind was I never
changed it in an argument.
Change it.
Yeah,
right.
I changed it in a conversation.
I don't mind changing my mind.
I think that's important too.
You know,
and I've,
I've changed my mind before and people
got mad at me,
bro.
You change your mind like,
yeah,
I changed my mind.
I learned some new stuff and then went,
oh,
okay,
I can't defend this old idea and I'm not
an idea.
Stupid.
The first.
What's the,
what's the first rule?
And being a scientist doubt,
uh,
ignorance.
You don't know anything and then you,
you make sure that you're responsive to
the evidence and then if you,
even if you build up a whole reputation
on your conclusion,
you have to be willing to change or
conclusion based upon new evidence.
And you have to,
you have a finished product.
Yeah,
exactly.
Your finished product.
Oh,
it's amazing.
You're a verb.
Yeah,
well I'm.
I'm definitely smarter than I was three
months ago.
It's different person to.
How about how about the differences in
you when you were 28 and now it's a
human person.
Yeah,
totally different human.
but that raises an interesting question
too,
so okay,
you're a very different person.
What if you did something awful?
Then let's maybe murder and now you're
in.
Should they let you go?
Right,
and now at 51,
I'm so different than when I was 21.
I don't remember that.
I was such a moron.
I was a moron at 30.
I remember feeling that awkward lack of
control I had for myself,
like feeling how awkward it was and we
wishing I had more composure.
I remember actively feeling that at 21
that it was so impulsive and so crazy
and I wished I was more composed and I
would see people that had their shit
together and I would really admire them.
I look at that guy all composed and shit
dressed nice,
knows what to say when not to say it.
Meanwhile,
blurt things out that I should never
say.
How about the way you look?
Like do.
I was thinking about the way I looked at
certain things like women and their
capabilities when I was a young man.
I did.
You know,
it changed me in looking at women in in
a different light,
the UFC and having children with a woman
and watching how good she wasn't raising
kids and all the things that that takes,
that's a certain type of strength and
then watching women like paige vanzant
fight three rounds with a broken arm
that that was all something that I
didn't think belonged.
That was an arena I was not aware of
that kind of feminine strength or
fortitude or whatever you want to call
it.
It causes me to look at that gender
differently than I did before.
So in a lot of ways I'm a different
person and as you get older,
that's what happens.
You see the world differently as you are
exposed to more data and exposed to more
and different paradigms and examples and
I think that's a good thing.
It is a good thing.
It's also,
it's ridiculous.
The female male debate back and forth is
ridiculous because people vary so much
inside those groups that for someone to
say,
all women do this,
women are all thinking this will be
like,
no,
that doesn't make any sense.
That's just as stupid as saying,
men do moon all dues.
All mandus.
No,
no,
that's not.
That doesn't make any sense.
What it fucking human beings.
There's a great number of men that do
this stupid thing and a great number of
women that say this annoying thing is a
great number of people that are just
looking to skate by in this life.
Men and women,
because a great number of dummies,
there's a great number of really
inspirational,
fantastic people that also have vaginas.
There's a lot of them had really smart
ones that blow your mind in a
conversation and they just happen to be
female and there's a lot of them that
are just happened to be male and they
they.
That male who happens to be fucking
brilliant and articulate and mindblowing
has almost no fucking relation to some
idiot shithead.
Ditch digger asshole.
Yeah.
Which nothing wrong with taking digital
folks.
Just don't dig ditches if you're an
asshole.
Trying to be.
No,
but it's also like if one of the things
I noticed,
you have a lot of people from different
backgrounds.
You got to Nigeria in this corner,
you've got Pakistan in that corner,
you've got China in that corner,
you've got fucking America.
You got a white guy from Iowa when they
all have to get food out to a group of
people in a restaurant or they gotta
figure out a way to run a business
together.
All that shit didn't.
Nobody has time for that shit.
Everybody's kind of working toward a
common goal.
Nobody has time.
If you actually have something important
to deal with when you don't have
something important to do,
start looking at like weird shit.
Like I fucking hate ginger's Ginger's
role.
The devil.
Now you start looking at things
different.
You know,
you start looking at the differences and
getting annoyed with stupid shit.
Yup.
Yeah.
I think all human beings,
just like your son have a physical
requirement.
There is a bond requirement that we all
have with each other.
There's a love requirement that we all
We have to get a certain amount of love.
You've got to have a certain amount of
bonding and comradery with the people
around you and these needs should be
legit,
like they give you like a vitamin C
chart.
USD,
a recommended daily allowance of Vitamin
C.
is this recommended daily allowance of
iron?
Is that like all that stuff is important
for your body?
I think you have an equally important
requirement for your.
Your mind?
Yes,
and for just your physical being like
not necessarily your body in terms of
like nutrition but just love and warmth.
Like the human touch,
you know the babies will die if you
don't touch them,
right?
Yeah.
It was called failure to thrive.
So in hospitals when they have babies
that don't have parents,
they have people that come around and
hold the babies.
She's not held.
You can feed the baby and everything.
If the baby's not held,
the baby will die.
Fuck,
I have to be touched by another human
being.
A baby has to.
Yeah.
It's like water or food.
That's a fucking requirement.
And I think that this,
this is being violated in schools when
you teach in little kids with tons of
energy and the way they cope with that
violation is give those kids medication
that makes them conform and we just
accept that.
And then people get on anti anxiety
medication and people get on all this
medication,
that medication and how many of these
medications are clearly described
because your life sucks or prescribed
rather because your life sucks.
How many of them is it?
Half?
Is it 30 percent?
Like what number of people actually have
something wrong with their brain and
what number of people have something
wrong with their brain because their
life sucks,
right?
God dammit.
I hate going over this same subject over
and over again because it's just so.
Well,
it's hard to hard to come up with
answers because it all depends.
It's drilling.
I was talking to Andy Galpin about that.
I was like,
well,
uh,
is,
is this vitamin good for you or is this
supplement could fee or is this.
I was showing him stuff I take and he
goes,
it depends.
It just depends on your body.
It depends on what you're.
What are you doing with your body,
what,
what is,
what is your routine like on a daily,
on a weekly basis,
what kind of stresses you putting your
body on?
Some things work,
some things don't.
There is no clear cut,
single variable answer.
It's just so fascinating that all of our
bodies have different requirements
because we literally developed in
different parts of the world.
I know and scooted over here in a boat.
Started fucking each other.
Oh,
look at you.
Allergic to cats.
Like all just weird things that stuck
with us.
I do better with goat dairy and me too
and I do with Mediterranean than I do
with Holstein cow dairy dude.
My daughter,
when she was little,
she would throw up if she drank cow's
milk,
but she would drink goat's milk and
she'd have no problem with it at all.
Yeah,
it's weird.
Ben,
like human dairy.
Well,
do you fuck with raw milk at all?
Yeah,
I used to,
but not anymore.
I'll fuck with raw goat milk.
I can't do raw milk.
A cow would rather get raw goat milk
because first of all,
do they treat goats the way they treat
cows?
I figure if you're running goats,
you probably like a little bit more
animal friendly goat milk in the world
from this amish from the Amish Shit.
It's which and creamy and delicious.
Would you imagine?
Let's go on a limb here and guess would
you imagine there's factory farming of
goats like milking commercial large?
Sure.
There is.
Like I get,
there's certain ultra pasteurized milk
called Meyers that I get.
Sometimes it's really good,
but it's ultra pasteurized,
but I'm sure that's that.
The problem is when you talk about
factory farming,
here's the problem,
right?
So we want consistency in our food.
So you want to buy eggs and you,
when you go to buy a carton of eggs,
you know they're going to cost a dollar
50 or $2 and 50 or $3 and 50,
whatever you,
you know that they're going to cost a
certain amount.
You don't go to the store and one day
they're three slash 50 and the next day
they're $12.
And the reason for that is this,
that we figured out a way to create
enough eggs so that there is enough of a
lot so that we can keep the price at a
certain level.
The problem with if you had all these
family farms.
Okay.
Which I've always been a fan as I always
talk about family farms versus factory
farms.
Awesome.
Brian never done a day of farming in my
fucking life.
Don't know anything about it,
but I done my reading.
So here's Brian again with his point of
view because he's read some stuff and he
likes eating at Erewhon and whole foods.
Okay.
Because I can afford it.
So I like family.
I've,
I like family's family.
Farming is bad.
The problem is that if you look at the
way farming it works is that some family
farms aren't as good as other family
farms for a thousand reasons that is not
as productive,
not as proficient.
So what would happen is that family
would say,
hey bro,
I know you're a chicken farmer too,
but you're not doing it right.
Let me buy your farm.
I'll buy your farm for 15 times.
What it's worth right now,
you need the money,
but I'm going to secretly,
I know I'm going to make my money back
because I know how I knew how to do it
better than that guy and then I do that.
Now I get up,
I go and buy a machine that's actually
faster and I go to the next form and I
say,
hey bro,
you're not going to compete with me on
the market anyway and you're not as
good.
Sell me your farm and what happens?
Is it going to go fuck you?
Not because you're not a city slicker.
He's a farmer himself talking to.
Don't like your attitude.
Hey Bro,
my fucking phone.
I could give you a deal.
Come over here.
I could,
I,
I not to make A.
I know what you're saying.
What people.
The real problem with factory farm is
the lack of moral standards,
like when they shove these chickens,
these little boxes.
And the other thing is we've adapted to
the ecosystem that we operate under and
the ecosystem that we operate under.
We get free food basically.
Yeah.
Not Free Food,
but a lot of protein.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's everywhere.
The food is just coming in and the eggs
are everywhere,
so someone's got to be able to make all
those eggs,
so we sort of develop these areas and
stacked them up with people based on the
idea that it's easy to get food here.
It was really hard to get food here in
the 18 hundreds.
It'd be 1500 people here,
right?
Yeah.
It would be like the desert,
but as people desert people live there.
Some people that this little ranch here
ranch there.
Why?
Because there's no fucking food man or
water.
Yeah,
there's not a lot there.
It's a desert.
Right.
So because of the fact that we figured
out how to be able to feed all these
millions and millions and millions of
people's.
Yeah.
Well in this one little spot like la in
particular where no one's growing,
shit,
everything shoved in there in terms of
humans and they're just pumping eggs in
there left and right.
Yeah.
They've sort populated that place
based on this ridiculous idea of the
access to meet.
It's not a ridiculous idea.
It's actually a reality.
Right,
right.
But then people come along and they see
a peta video and then they go,
hey,
but you still want to live here,
so while you're going to have to go
vegan then,
well guess what?
If you do that,
they're going to have to chop down a lot
of fucking trees and start growing food
everywhere.
They're going to have to put it
All these people are going to be Vegan,
all 2 million in this town and 6 million
in the neighborhood town and then $20
million in la.
A lot of agricultural runoff and
pollution.
You're going to have a lot of fucking
shit go into the ground.
You're going to have a lot of combines
chewing up rabbits and rats,
ground nesting birds.
Everything's.
Everything's going to get buzzed up.
When you gathering up all that grain,
you're going to need to feed all those 2
million people that don't have access to
animal protein anymore.
That's not good either.
Right?
We're fucked is what I'm saying.
You're giving up that easy.
I give up.
I think technology is allowing us to
grow more food on less land.
So that's true.
I think I'm very hopeful for that.
Um,
uh,
artificial meat,
that meat,
they're growing very hopeful for that
because if we could figure out a way to
make it healthy to get that kind of
meat,
you would still have population control
problems and I think I would never stop
hunting because of that.
But it's,
it's meat without a central nervous
system.
Eat without a central nervous system and
we could probably,
if it's done and it really works.
I mean there's a lot of ifs there,
but we could probably eliminate most of
the factory farming.
The real problem would be like,
what would you do with all those cows?
What do you do with the cows now?
They would die off and then you wouldn't
have,
but you don't want them to go extinct,
you know,
have some cows because there'll be
people who it'd be a whole marketplace
of eating meat with the central nervous
system.
Just watch,
I'll do it.
Definitely is natural.
We go back to the.
There's always going to be a marketplace
for eating food as it quote unquote
occurred naturally.
Which of course Holstein cows are not
[inaudible].
The other thing I was going to get to
the problem with letting them go,
if we ever let them go,
they morph sort of like the same way
pigs morph.
They become this thing called scrub
bulls.
You ever heard of scrub bowls?
It's a really,
uh,
it's really popular.
Especially in Australia.
They're wild cattle cattle really broken
through fences and lived many,
many generations in the wild men.
The males are super aggressive.
Very dangerous.
Jamie,
let me see.
Yeah,
they're dangerous.
Is Fuck enormous.
Enormous bull.
They're not afraid of lions.
Afraid of water buffalo.
They can climb a tree.
When you see a water buffalo.
Well,
my friend Adam Green tree who shot that
buffalo above the flag and I'm in the
north lands.
That's a scrub bull.
So you see how weird that thing looks?
It looks weird because it's probably
lived in the wild for many,
many,
many generations.
They're huge.
Look at the size of the sack on him.
Dude,
look at his sack and look at his hog.
Holy Shit.
Things.
No joke.
That thing is laying pipe all day.
Just just banging all these cows
did.
They're enormous wild cows and they're
very aggressive.
The males in particular will fuck you up
because they're not steers.
Right?
There are bowls.
When we're getting steak,
you're getting steak most of the time
from a a steers and animal.
They cut the balls off of it when it's
young.
These are full as bowls with the muscles
on that.
That animal look at the size of that.
That thing's huge.
Jesus.
Yeah.
These are big fucking wild bulls.
You know,
what does that weigh?
Eighteen hundred pounds or some shit.
Oh Man.
Fuck.
So that would happen in America.
You got to recognize that if people
stopped having domestic cattle and they
just let those cattle roam through,
you would have a devastating impact on
the ecosystem just like you have with
wild pigs.
It would be similar.
You'd have one.
You have those cows would all be
euthanized or they be eating and then
maybe it's,
it's,
it's blinding the cows,
but you'd have to have a certain
population of them that we keep alive
what it needed for milk,
you know,
can milk them if they come up with
artificial mill.
Goddammit.
Joe.
Fuck.
You're not really supposed to drink milk
though,
right?
I mean not really,
but cheese is good.
Shit.
Is it though?
I drink.
I cheese and I drink wine.
It doesn't make me feel good and I'm
never stopping.
How about that one does not make me feel
good until it goes in my mouth.
The problem is if I,
if I like I was in that makeup chair and
you drink in one I was doing now was
puffy in the morning and I looked at the
makeup woman and I said,
I think and I said,
why?
Why am I so puffy in the morning?
And she goes,
are you drinking at nine ago?
Every night?
She goes,
well,
don't do that.
If you have to shoot the next day,
you might not want to drink three
glasses of wine because I get swollen.
Just drink it.
Yeah,
but I want to know.
Do you want to look good?
Dairy reinvented,
sustainable kind.
Delicious.
There you go.
Animal Free Milk.
I bet that thing gives.
You can lock it.
Farts.
Farts that if you were at a a chair with
wheels on it,
you could partner with.
Scoot you across a carpet.
I mean,
how could your body want?
Digest that.
What's that stuff made outta?
Give me some ingredients on Jamie.
Weird people are weird.
Milk Almond milk.
That's my favorite son.
Even.
Yeah.
There's no almond entities that's not
almond milk.
So whenever a joke like that,
that's someone's joked.
I just bite someone's joke.
I don't think so.
The whole almond milk thing is so weird.
You're just soaking nuts and then
getting the dirty water.
They know what it's like.
It's like when you a eat coco pops
cuckoo for cocoa puffs and you would
have that chocolate in there.
Would that be the chocolate?
No.
Bottom.
Press them.
God it.
What are you talking about?
They stay,
they take the almonds,
they soak them,
they sprout them,
right,
but then they press them.
Right,
but that dirty water,
it's just water.
The almonds were soaking around it?
No,
because they don't do it that way,
I don't think.
I think
the way they do it as they crushed the
almonds after they've been.
After they had been soaked,
they take the skin off and then they.
They crushed them and then they mix it.
They crushed them and then they press
them and it creates like a milky.
It's dirty water.
I don't know what kind of fucking almond
factor when you're talking about bro.
It's dirty.
Almond water.
What is your.
I'm genetically engineered yeast.
What does,
what is this?
This is.
What's the cellular ag?
What?
Vegan milk.
It's called.
Oh my God.
The term genetically.
Wow.
The team used genetically engineered
yeast to pro produce six key proteins.
Oh God.
Damn motherfucker.
Six key proteins that provide the
texture and plants to harvest ate fatty
acids that contribute to the flavor.
Finally they add sugars,
minerals,
and water.
Easy peasy.
It's sugar.
With this straightforward recipe,
the composition can be modified to leave
potentially harmful components such as
cholesterol and hormones out of the
equation.
Kind of lactose cholesterol by the way,
the building blocks of all cells.
Yeah.
Isn't lack sugar.
Google that back there.
Yeah,
they're putting sugar in there,
man,
but they said they put sugars in it
because otherwise it would taste like
donkey piss.
Yeah.
East.
By the way,
east is a life form.
Where do you draw the line?
Like if you're a Vegan and you're eating
yeast,
you are eating a living thing.
You're eating a life form that if you
didn't eat it,
it would replicate.
It's not a plant.
It's a life form.
[inaudible] like if you're.
If you're eating probiotics,
like say if you're a Vegan,
you eating probiotics,
you are eating a little tiny light
forms.
That's what you're eating.
When you have fermented that you're
letting animals grow on your food and
you're eating your food and the animals,
so like that's where I get my protein.
You're eating animals,
you're eating little tiny,
tiny little animals.
I think one,
10,
nine out of 10 of your cells are not
human.
They're bacteria.
Every cell of your body is made from it,
and all of your steroid hormones,
hormones are synthesized from
cholesterol,
including all of the sex and adrenal
hormones.
Well,
you definitely don't want that in your
body.
Then do you.
Why would you want something that's
responsible for every fucking cell in
your body?
Like this idea that,
that diet is better for you is so
Goddamn cockamamie.
They're telling you that they're putting
in sugar so that it makes it palatable
and taking you.
You don't have to worry about that
naughty cholesterol that's responsible
for every fucking cell in your body and
your hormones.
We don't want that.
Have it.
They're not even paying attention to
science,
but it's a belief system.
It's not.
It's like,
here's what it is though.
Here's where it gets weird.
The,
this is,
uh,
I also believe in many ways is a left
right thing that the left believes in
climate change science wholeheartedly,
100 percent,
but does not believe in gender is gender
size.
No,
that's all bullshit.
If you,
if you,
if you talk about the difference between
male and female xy chromosomes,
they'll shut you down.
Did you see bret Weinstein's,
his wife?
I heard they were hiring Eric Weinstein.
No,
I'm his wife,
heather hiding.
She was doing a speech,
uh,
with James Demore.
Uh,
they were talking about gender diversity
and she's just talking about the
difference between males and females.
From a scientist point of view.
She's a,
she's a real biologist,
right?
People get up and screaming.
They're shutting her down there,
walking out.
They knocked over the sound system.
They called her a fascist.
Oh,
he said he's a Nazi.
You're against science,
but it's amazing.
It's amazing.
So dumb.
But it's this thing,
this left right thing to.
It's right.
It's like the left.
Once you do 100 percent buy into
whatever science they accept,
but also they don't buy into a lot of
shit that just doesn't fit with whatever
their ideology I left.
Isn't the cultural purity the far
right's into racial period?
Yeah,
but it was the denial of sciences and
new thing.
Yes.
It's denial of science was just not a
part of the left.
The left was always pro science posted,
supposedly pro science that the idea was
that they were more educated,
but as I looked into it,
I felt it was like,
that's not really true,
but you would think that it would be
more educated because they can.
Is it left and right or is it just.
Is it,
is it.
Are we talking about just people who
are.
I feel like when we talk about these
people that are not going to have a
sound systems and walking out and
shouting that Christine and summers,
I don't know that they're right or left.
I think that these are young,
young,
confused people.
Shitheads shit.
Yeah.
I think that I really do.
I think they're proud.
First of all.
I don't think they're very smart.
I don't think that that's absolutely
true.
I think a lot of them might have some
psychological problems.
I think a lot of them want to belong.
I think a lot of them just want to be
heard and people do clumsy shit.
When people want to feel significant,
they'll do even crazier shit,
like put a gun in their hand and shoot
somebody so sure,
you know,
and it usually it belongs.
It's the realm of young people who don't
know what to do with their energy.
There's a lot of that.
And again,
like we talked about before with
Christina Hoff summers,
there's just a bunch of people that are
free from their parents for the first
time.
That's right.
You know,
they've only been free for 24 months and
they're stretching,
they're dyed their hair green.
You can't stop me,
you fascist and I just,
yeah,
I just want to stop everything and they
want attention.
But ultimately I think that this is
giving us an opportunity to really fully
examine ideas and even though these
people shouting people down,
all those noises going on,
like there'll,
there'll be a result.
They'll be some sort of an ebb and flow
to all this that I feel very hopeful
about.
Like when I look at the ebb and flow of
things,
like I like it.
I like what's going on.
I like that there's a lot of fucking
chaos and definitely some people have
taken some unsafe unnecessarily bullets
and there's definitely some ideas that
are getting shut down that shouldn't be
and there's definitely some overuse the
word Nazi and fascist and all this
different stuff,
but it seems like overwhelmingly all
this crazy energy is being pushed into
at least the idea that we're improving
the world.
Yeah,
you know what I'm saying?
They want to improve the world.
I had a bunch of women on my podcast.
We were talking about sexism in
Hollywood and of course I was like,
I don't see it that much.
I was like,
I don't say it,
and these women were all really
intelligent and I said,
you know,
I gotta be honest man.
As a white man now I just feel like I,
it's just,
it's hard for us.
I go,
you know,
I gotta watch what I say now I've got to
watch how I talk.
And,
and one of the women goes,
Katie goes,
wow,
I can't imagine what that's like one.
What's it like to have to watch it?
Watch what you say and watch.
Watch what your impact is like.
I have no idea.
Meanwhile she's been dealing with that.
Every woman I know has been dealing with
that for fucking ever and I guess I
didn't take it.
I didn't look at their perspective.
It's hard to look at other people's
perspective.
Yeah,
it is.
It's hard to.
Like
I was talking to shop in the last
podcast we were talking about a Joey
Diaz had some crazy shit about some
chicks ass and uh,
and we were all laughing about it.
He was like,
it's Joey's fucking Diaz.
He's a comedian.
I go,
I totally understand and I'm with you.
But now imagine if you were a regular
sized guy and you were dealing with some
seven foot tall ogre who was going
online talking about how good your
asshole smelled.
And you're like,
oh Jesus.
And you knew that that guy wanted to
fuck you.
And then you knew that if he was alone
with you,
he could probably like hold you down and
fuck you.
Like that would be terrifying,
right?
Yeah,
that'd be terrifying.
In this case,
he's talking about a female fighter.
Probably would fuck joey.
His ass probably beat Joe.
His ass.
Bad Ass.
You know Joey's not in the best shape.
He might.
He might call clock
punched out.
She starts circling,
is jagged.
She's scared she's going to pepper his
face a little bit,
but either way he's being funny.
That's all it is.
But I was saying about.
Imagine now though that your a girl who
hear someone talk about your asshole
like that and we've all done it.
We've all done it.
Yeah.
You'd be like,
oh no.
Like that's got to be a terrible
feeling.
Yeah,
it is.
It's interesting.
I'd love to be a woman for one day to
see what.
That's what you'd like to get fucked.
If you're a woman for one day,
we just suck a dick.
No,
wouldn't you like,
that's where I draw the line in there.
I only want to see where it goes.
I just want to see what it's like.
Like what does it feel like?
Like stuck it in your ass.
Like I could have found that out.
I was a guy.
Well,
first of all,
what's it like to be attracted to a man
like I look at you and I know women find
attractive.
I don't find you attractive.
Beautiful,
right area,
right?
But to have this big kind of a good
side,
this guy,
you got a strong jaw,
smaller,
strong jaw,
smolder God,
you do smaller and smaller and smaller.
It's hard.
It's hard for you to.
I get lost in your eyes.
You have a strong Johnson.
Well,
imagine wanting someone to stick
something in you and shoot,
shoot sperm and two.
You can't wait.
Get some in me.
Yeah,
imagine that.
Yeah.
Jamie just threw up.
Like
my wife was watching Sopranos and she
found time sprinter.
Attractive when I said why?
She goes because he's powerful and he's
just bad and he's and,
and you know,
and I said,
well we want to be married to him.
She goes,
I don't want to be married to him.
I want to be as mistress.
I was like,
what the fuck?
God.
Leave the room.
I know I gotta I got to gain weight.
I would make tea and I was think about
my life.
I got to stop being so shredded.
I've got to get into crime and gained
some weight instead of being so good.
Yeah.
Just eat some pasta.
So legit and terrific up.
Yeah,
he died young.
That was a bummer.
If it's one of those guys that when he
died I was like,
oh,
55 or 52 or something.
Shit.
He was in that neighborhood.
Looked every bit of 60.
Yeah.
He had it all in his system to baby.
Yeah,
he did,
right?
He had the full ride.
He likes to do well.
I know guys have worked with them.
I know guys well who worked with him and
he just.
He could fucking tear it up man.
Who's the movie though?
Played a hitman.
What was that movie?
True Romance?
No,
no.
Yeah.
Was that one but there was a more recent
one.
I'm God damn it.
Was it with Brad Pitt?
Was there,
moved with him and Brad Pitt killing me
softly.
Yes.
Was he a Hitman to.
They were both Hitman,
but he was also in the drop.
I don't know if you're thinking about
that.
I'm thinking of killing me softly.
That's the one,
right?
He was great and true romance,
man.
Fuck.
He's great and everything.
It was amazing.
I mean that Tony Soprano's character
literally literally changed gene,
what we think of as like a hero in a TV
show because all of a sudden the hero
was a murderer,
like the hero.
Like when he killed Christopher,
like when they had the car accident,
you just fucking smothered him.
He's like,
this is a good excuse to kill this guy.
I just killed him right there.
I was like,
whoa.
Holy Shit.
When he closed his nose.
Yeah,
man,
that was fucked up.
There's no class that was fucked up.
Yeah,
I know.
That's what it was like.
That's willing to do whatever it took.
Yeah,
but it was also the star,
the movie,
The star of the show.
And you liked him?
Oh yeah.
That's what was so genius.
There's never been a show like,
that is so bad.
Look,
he was so bad and there's.
There hasn't been a show like that since
then.
I mean,
who else is like that much of a villain
and a hero wrapped up into one?
Who else?
What other?
The only person that you can maybe
breaking bad,
but you could see why he was doing it.
It wasn't a bad guy.
Tony Soprano's was a Hemi badge,
cheated on his wife,
constantly murdered,
killed,
but it was the.
What was fascinating about him is that
it was the dichotomy.
It was the guy who loved his family,
told the son to do his homework and not
to swear at the table and also an order
a hit in the same breath.
That insane contradiction was what?
You can't take your eyes off because
we're bipolar reps because you can be a
very bad guy and also a really good guy
and that's what's.
That's what's fucking crazy and true
about human beings.
Well,
that's what's brilliant though about
that writing is that they figured out
how to encapsulate that in fiction where
it's playing out every week and you're
not.
You're not sick of the guy like you want
to.
You want to see if he's going to make
it.
Is he going to get busted?
Is he going to jail or they gonna crack
down on them.
Who's going to rat them out,
you know,
but that,
that shows an interesting like kind of
metaphor for life.
Like I guess what I really worry about
with our social situation today is the
destruction of people and how they're
never allowed to come back into the
fold.
That's what I worry about.
Like,
like public shaming or whatever it might
be.
Like there are very few people that
deserve eternal damnation and they are
out there,
but for the most part,
Roman Polanski.
It's a tough,
you know,
again,
a great artist and a great filmmaker on
reacting to the fact that you,
I can't,
I can't justify having you come back to
the country and be pardoned after that.
If the,
if what you did is true.
If what I've been,
what I've read and been told is true,
I don't know how I'm supposed to forgive
that so that that's mainly because a
child and so that falls into line of
unacceptable things for me,
but then there's people that have been
shamed like Al Franken where you're
like,
really?
No.
That was ridiculous.
It was ridiculous.
What did he do?
What I get to the photo was very
inappropriate that he took the end.
You can't just train him.
Funny Weinstein.
That cheapens.
No,
you can't.
He shouldn't have done it,
but he was trying to be funny and
sometimes people try to be funny,
especially people are around each other
all the time.
They get stupid and they,
they crossed lines and you know,
or you just don't read the signals.
You Cross a line in that you're trying
to pick somebody up or you're putting
pressure on them.
Don't you think that ultimately what
this is going to do though is people are
going to have to learn to be nicer to
each other.
Don't you think that?
Or they're going to be really careful
and afraid and I worry that if you have,
for example,
first of all,
where do people,
most people meet their wives and their
girlfriends?
A lot of times it's a work a lot of
times,
okay,
their husbands and their wives and I
think that your don't be surprised if
corporations start to have a zero
tolerance policy for any kind of romance
in the office space.
It'll be like the military.
Nobody's allowed to date anybody and if
you do get fired right away,
no questions asked,
and now think about the fact that your
eight hours a day in this place,
which is most of your waking hours to
make anybody happy.
I can make anybody happy.
Also,
please add the fact that we're also
going to have all of the meetings
between men and women in rooms
videotaped and in fact d and in fact,
men and women aren't allowed to be in
the same room without a chaperone.
Yes,
you're going to see all the shit
chaperones role because you're talking
about major money.
You're talking about major fucking.
It'd be a robot with a camera.
The robot,
it says,
I think you were speaking inappropriate
thing.
Exactly.
And so you have all these issues,
so is that going to make all of us
happier?
No,
we're going to have to quit.
Is it going to make us work in offices?
We're going to be safer.
I'm hoping that it makes people quit
offices.
So what happens is there will be no
sexual harassment at the workplace
because there's no workplace.
Fuck,
I never thought of that dude.
Dude,
way ahead.
You're smarter.
We're working together.
Not Working together now.
That's Kinda why I show up and work
together.
Fuck.
By the way,
men and women working together as a
pretty new thing in history.
Yeah.
Men and women boys.
Men and women have never worked
together.
Yeah.
So this is all kind of like and you
know,
you know,
listen,
when men and women get together,
people are starting to fuck.
Whoa,
they're just gonna Fuck Whitney.
Cummings was a funny joke about that,
but working in the writing room,
working on a set of a show like she
doesn't usually work like at a place and
she's like,
oh,
this is what people are doing here.
Like,
yeah,
I don't want to give away her joke.
It's very funny,
but yeah,
that's,
you know,
there's something that's happening when
men and women get around each other,
they're jockeying for sexual position
and they're attracted to each other and
they worked together and they ended up
liking each other.
Yeah.
And then they get to know each other at
work and.
Yeah.
And then what happens.
Okay.
So you can see you can't.
So there's no such and there's no
romance and there's no humor.
Humor is dangerous.
Humor can be a problem.
What if you say something racist and
you're trying to be funny.
You get in trouble.
Don't do that.
You're not racist,
but you were just trying to be funny.
Right.
Okay.
But you can say racist things.
I'll give you a free pass to say racist
things about white people.
Well that's fine.
I'll give you a free pass.
Do you have any racist white things that
you could say at work today?
Tommy?
Yeah.
Couldn't they be hillbillies?
Yes.
Or rednecks.
Rednecks.
Dirty hillbillies.
That's fine.
Shit.
All over those people that were forced,
their whole family worked at a coal
mine.
Yeah.
Hey,
how you dummies?
Will you fucking your kids?
Uh,
yeah.
It'd be racist all day for white people.
You can and there's some white people
that do not have a fucking good deal.
They don't have a good deal.
No.
They got $400 in the bank if that.
There's some incredible amount of money,
uh,
or an incredible amount of people rather
in this country that have less than that
in their bank through.
Yeah.
There was something like 50 percent,
some study they did.
People that have $200 or less in their
bank account and some insane number like
into the millions and millions of
people.
This is what I always say,
that people that voted for trump,
you know,
a lot of them have been demonized by,
the left as being a racist or homophobic
or massage seats and stuff like that.
Yeah.
Or or,
or good people who have $400 in the bank
or less,
can't send their kids to baseball,
et cetera.
And along comes Hillary Clinton,
who's Obama light talking about the same
shit.
And they were like,
I'll try anything but her.
Look at this.
There you go.
That's real.
Read that.
That's real man.
Six in 10 Americans don't have $500 in
savings.
There you go.
Holy Shit.
It's way more than I thought it was when
you don't have one.
Okay,
now,
now we're back to that.
That story about scarcity.
Isn't that like a hundred and $50,
million people or something like that?
Yeah,
60 percent.
It's more than.
Yeah.
So,
so how does the,
what is the real number of people in
America is a 300 million or morning or
something at 3:30.
Three 30.
So it's more than that.
Yeah.
So,
so one 70 170 million people.
So when you got $500 a month,
are you thinking about gender neutral?
Bathrooms?
Always.
Are you thinking about that?
No.
Everyone's massages,
bro.
It's disgusting to be a man and see
other men's.
I'm just ashamed of my gender.
I'm ashamed.
All your fucking thinking about is
getting my money so you can send your
kids to fucking think.
Bret Weinstein said that was really
interesting about this.
Is it better?
Eric and Eric?
There's brothers.
They're brothers.
They both been on my podcast.
Eric is a mathematician who works for
Peter.
Teal is the professor from Evergreen
College that got the day of absence
where they made him quit because there
was.
There were saying white people need to
stay home.
Everybody's like,
that's so racist.
He's also a Jew.
The Jews.
We super,
super,
super progressive.
It doesn't matter.
The Jews didn't exactly have it easy
what he was saying.
That's interesting.
You were saying that this is not just
about that.
It's also about subordination and that
you're seeing this subordination plate
that's planning,
that's taking place,
and then a lot of these men like the way
they're behaving,
they're behaving to be subordinate
there.
There.
There are being obedience trained,
you know,
and they're.
They're giving into it to show that you
shouldn't punish me because I'm on your
side because they were terrified of the
women that are wielding this power now,
but I got up in the air building that
wild.
I've got a theory about that.
Brilliant men.
Historically,
when you create a bunch of quiet resent
and it turns into allowed violence,
men are really good at.
You've got to be careful about make a
masculine men a wholesale because I
always worry that it's very easy to whip
them up when you got the right
circumstances and the right leader and
men like to organize and they liked to
fight and they like to fight back and
that's what makes them feel significant
when they've been emasculated and I
don't think it's,
you know,
that's the expression.
Punishment doesn't change behavior.
It just suppresses it.
Well.
Do you know that in the turn of the
century,
I'm not this one,
but the last,
there was a giant bachelor culture in
America where men just didn't.
They had just gotten through like a lot
of it was like in the twenties to like
an after the depression.
It was like the burden of having a
family was just too much.
It wasn't attractive to them and there
was a bunch of men that gravitate
towards pool halls and in
19 early 19 hundreds of New York City,
there was more than 900 pool halls in
New York City to just stop and think of
that more than 900 pools and there's all
these men that would just go there and
they would hang out and they were like,
fuck that life,
and they just didn't want to have a part
of it because it was too brutal.
It was too hard.
They're all this country would need for
this thing to flip on its fucking ass.
All they would need is legalized
prostitution and guys would be like,
wait,
hold up,
wait a minute,
hold on,
hold on.
I definitely love you.
I'd definitely love you,
but wait a minute,
wait a minute.
What am I signing?
What is this?
If if people found out that they could
just get sex anytime they wanted,
if they had $100,
like if you have $100,
you can get sex and you get sex and a
pretty girl and it's clean.
You don't have to worry about it.
People would be outraged.
Like,
well,
how am I going to have power over this
man?
If I can't control his sex,
I could only.
I only have him locked.
Otherwise we're just friends.
See if we're just friends,
I can't have half his money.
I can't tell him what to do.
I can't tell him when to be home,
but let me ask you a question.
We have to live together and I have to
control his sex.
If we live together and then I control
his sex,
then I have all this power.
But if they were in a situation where
legalized prostitution was just like
grocery stores or it's just everywhere.
What would the first of all,
the amount of hose would probably be the
same.
It's like used to be a lot richer.
Now they're just doing it like under the
table.
It's hard to get away with it.
They can get rated as sneakiness.
There's all this,
you know,
the gold diggers instead of hose.
Some girls would just go straight into
heroin.
Yeah.
But here's my question.
Do you think men are more interested in
sex or admiration?
There's both.
They want to be fake admiration from the
hose.
Yeah,
but they say with all due respect,
no,
it's fake though.
Like I think men can do want to be
admired more than anything else they do.
They do.
They want their dick to be the biggest.
Even if it's a mushroom cap,
just make all the noise please and let
me know I'm King Kong and that's why.
And you stick to the woman.
A lot of times you'll stick that one
woman who you know has got your back no
matter what you're talking about.
A guy who finds that there's a lot of
people that don't find that in for them.
Legalized prostitution right next to
Bolero.
Hop on in Chanera go sandwich Dick,
suck.
Get a grilled cheese and tomato soup
kitchen.
Like it would change.
Like what people like why,
why are you dating?
Are you dating specifically for sex or
dating because you want companionship,
like are you too consumed with work and
are you busy all day and you just like
to hang out with your friends but you
get horny?
Yeah,
because we have a solution for you.
And if that was the case.
I'm not saying that relationships
wouldn't be the same,
but I'm saying is there's a lot of
relationships that wouldn't be the same
too.
I think you're onto something like my
buddy Steve,
he blew it.
He was like,
he would have stayed in jail if he had
access to women because he was hanging
out with all his friends.
He
was like,
it was the fucking best best because all
we do is fuck around and laugh all day,
lift weights,
and you know,
he just did food kind of sucks,
but you're all laughing and you're all
in a shitty situation.
Situations.
Everybody gets along.
He goes,
if I had girls,
if I had access to women,
I would not have left.
That's hilarious.
This is in Fort Dix to like,
you know,
the biggest federal penitentiary in the
world.
I'm obviously torn on prostitution
because I don't want anybody that I know
kids or my kids to go into prostitution,
but I also don't think anybody should
tell people that something that's
completely legal to do for free is
illegal to charge money for.
Yeah.
Like there is some gay male escort that
came out today.
Uh,
there was,
I put it on my twitter about like,
just let these fucking people have sex.
Like some gay male escort was talking
about the priests at the Vatican and
he's like,
naming names.
I fuck that guy.
I fucked him.
I fuck pan.
He wants us,
my dad,
him and you know,
they was talking about them being
hypocritical.
Like,
yeah,
there are definitely hypocritical.
Let these fucking people have sex.
This is crazy.
Like your,
your system doesn't work.
Yeah.
If they just let them have sex and let
them have male escorts,
just leave them alone.
Say That's fine.
Just as long as you do.
You believe in Jesus still.
Yeah.
Just like Dick,
I believe in Jesus,
but I love Dick.
Okay,
well Jesus must've put that love for
Dick in you.
Jesus.
Put that love for our truth.
Sure.
Right.
It must have been.
The truth is
it's a complicated thing,
right?
Because then where do you.
So,
so like we had these urges and a lot of
them are not very productive,
right?
So you want to have sex with all,
you want to have sex with everybody you
can or whatever it might be,
but you know,
that's not viable because there are just
certain trade offs
do that.
Well,
you know,
the,
the viable alternatives x Mokena you
have these ai robot fuck dolls that live
in your house,
but the problem is they probably get too
smart than they kill your real wife.
You know the algorithm.
Yeah.
And they figured out a way to convert
your sperm into babies.
They just,
they've figured out a way to create an
actual digital wound.
Could idea for from movie dude.
Well it's x Monkey Manchino that movie.
Did you see that now?
Oh my God.
It's one of my all time favorite.
Yeah.
I want to top top 20 all time.
Favorite movies.
I'm obsessed with Black Mirror.
It's an hour and 45 minute black mirror.
X market is amazing.
Yeah,
I do love Black Mirror.
It's awesome.
But x market is actually even more
intense.
It's a really well done movie about Ai
and uh,
it's,
it has very few cut the shit scenes.
Like when you're,
when you're watching it,
you're like,
whoa.
Like all of this could be possible in a
hundred percent.
Yeah.
It's really good.
I want to tell you anymore.
It's really good to watch it.
Yeah,
it's,
it's the shit.
And it's also.
Yeah.
That would be the move.
What do you think?
It's so fun.
It's going to eat us.
You think what I think?
How about this?
Um,
Boston makes those fucking robots that
you can't kick over.
Do you know those things?
Yeah.
And they,
they are funded by Darpa and Darpa makes
a robot called the eater robot e a t our
robot and the eater robot literally eats
biological material.
I'll spell that out for you.
It's fucking people.
It eats dead people on the battlefield
to fuel itself.
It is an actual working concept of a
fucking robot that eats dead people for
fuel.
Yes.
E a t o will.
It can eat hay and maybe sticks and
rabbits.
Maybe delete a rabbit.
It's going to eat people you fuck way,
way autonomous tactical robot eater
project.
Uh,
it's from a Darpa.
It's.
Yeah.
What's Darpa you highlighting there?
What's dark?
Oh,
it's a video.
So I'm looking at the cursor doing that.
I'm like,
why are you highlighting Darpa?
Darpa is.
I forget the something research.
It's all military shit.
Darpa is a robot.
Yes.
Yeah,
it's a real thing.
Yeah.
It's a real thing that the same people
that are making those Boston dynamic
robots,
you just see the one recently that it
bounces.
It pulls up to the side of a wall and
then bounces over the wall like 13 feet
in the air.
No lands on top of a building.
It could land on the roof of a building.
Come on from the bottom and hop all the
way up to the second story.
Building two story building.
It leaps literally from the ground all
the way to the top itself.
It's on wheels,
so it writes itself perfectly every
time.
That's so fucking,
dude.
It's so bananas and all this stuff is
happening.
Like while people are paying attention
to Kim Kardashian's ass.
Even Jamie,
Jamie's like,
oh,
Kim Kardashian called out the easy mafia
today.
Like,
did you like her?
You like her a camera dash,
and he is.
He loves celebrity gossip and upset of
how I met your mother and she was there
and we were.
We were like,
her dressing room was right next to mine
that she was on set and she didn't look
like what I thought she was.
She didn't have any makeup.
She's pretty and all,
but it was just like,
I didn't even know that I was hurt.
I was like,
I think that's Kim Kardashian.
I'm not sure.
It's a.
she's a person.
She's.
We've made a bizarre choice to spend a
tremendous and me included spend a
tremendous amount of talent,
tremendous,
tremendous amount of time thinking about
a person that really doesn't do a thing.
Like they just live like that's what's
weird.
It's like she,
they've tapped into this extreme desire
for gossip and some weird,
crazy way where they do all these wacky
things with life where you can't take
your eyes off of them and they always
have something new going on,
but they don't do anything.
So now she got wise though and married a
guy who does other thing.
She'd married Kanye West,
right?
He's a giant cultural thing.
Yeah.
So then now it becomes more legit.
Now the whole empire is like really
solidified,
like they've added some fucking sand.
It's ambition,
ambition.
It's just like this strange.
It's definitely that.
There's ambition,
but there's also this.
They've figured out how to Juke the
system.
They figured out how to Shuck and jive
and make their way in with no singing,
no dancing,
no comedy into money.
I think I have money,
but what do you do?
Anything different than you did like
besides not worry so much about what a
car is going to cost,
but what do you do that's luxurious?
I don't really do much,
man addressed.
Those are dress I know address normal
work.
I work out,
I go running.
What do you do?
Is there any advice you'd like hunting
on advice though?
That's where I get my.
Maybe this is what I mean is like I
don't spend.
Right.
I have my standup.
I like to box.
I like to uh,
you know,
the things I do don't take that much
money.
They take a lot of time and energy.
I think if you wanted to travel and you
wanted to go on some big time
adventures,
which I have decided I'm really
interested in doing some adventure.
Some your especially hunting adventures.
I like to go to New Zealand,
New Zealand.
We should go to his farm.
I would love to.
I'd love to go to.
I want to bow hunt in Alaska and the
Yukon wild coats on his property there.
Wild.
Huh?
Go.
I don't know,
but there are wild.
He's got his New Zealand's insane.
New Zealand is really like an
experimentation in um,
invasive species because everything is
invasive.
They have red stag that are from Europe
and they have all these axes.
Actually,
I don't know if they have access to.
He's got huge red stag on his property
that shoots their clearance.
They have some immense animals there and
they don't have any predators,
so they have these crazy seasons where
you could just shoot things all the
time.
Oh,
there's a while.
Go look at a cool horns on that thing,
man.
That's what he should fuck.
That's amazing.
Look at that thing.
I know.
It's like the ripples of a jelly fish
when it's in the water.
You want to go?
We can go look at that fucking thing.
That's a New Zealand Wild Goat,
Huh?
Yeah.
Wow.
Those horns are beautiful.
Look at the code on that thing.
What are the amazing animal?
I know they're smart.
I was watching a thing online about
these guys that were hunting for big
horn sheep,
you know,
and there were uh,
in the rocky mountains hunting for rocky
mountain bighorn sheep with a bow and
arrow.
And I was looking at these things and
I'm like,
what a crazy animal.
You remember we saw them and we're in
Montana.
And rinella was pointing out the size of
their balls.
Yes,
because they have like church bell
balls.
Do they have,
they're so athletic to keep each other
in the balls.
They do.
They kick each other in the balls when
they were living there,
like be jockeying for attention.
They had buddy each other,
which is why they have those antlers in
the first place and then they walk up
behind each other and lift their feet up
and kick each other in the balls.
I didn't see that constantly.
They crash into each other though.
It's incredible dude.
And they're so athletic.
I was up in Bisque,
big whiskey mountain in Wyoming and me
and my buddy hiking and he discussed,
he just pointed at and they were just
seven of them.
I wrote with them and they are fucking
huge there.
Three hundred pounds.
Yeah.
Giant animals.
Look at these fuckers.
Look at what a cool animal too.
Like when you look at the things,
got some balls,
the horns on their head.
We're the sack.
Once they collide,
look at his sack on the right just
swinging.
How crazy did they don't have any head
trauma while they're probably dumb as
fuck.
I mean seriously.
What do they have to do?
I smell mountain lion.
They're not doing algorithms.
Yeah,
their food is right in front of her
fucking stupid face all the time.
Here it goes.
Boom.
And they snap into it too.
It's not like they're running into their
head down there.
They're putting all this extra emphasis
in.
They're trying to make it uncomfortable
for the other dude.
The crazy thing is when you see two
bucks and they're orange get tied up
together.
That's crazy.
But what's crazy about this is that they
pause afterwards so they must get their
bell rung.
Right?
But look,
they just stand there and they back up
like no one is like,
bitch,
I hit you again and now hit you with
again.
You're right,
right.
Watch what they do.
Take a days,
didn't find a bucket,
must be lunches.
Boom.
And then they built.
They're both like,
what is happening here?
Oh Jesus.
They turned to sideways.
Almost like the one.
Ignore the fact that the guys there.
Wow,
look at this guy.
I wonder if they see cool shit.
Like,
look,
what else?
You butterflies and fairies.
Fairies.
His came up off the ground.
Do they hit each other so hard,
but they just stop.
Look,
they hit each other and then they just
chill out.
When you're getting off on it,
it's like they're getting some kind of a
high.
I wonder if anybody's ever observed like
a wonder if there'd be a way to measure
like certain neuro transmitters on them,
like inaction,
like let them collide with each other
and then figure out like what happens to
the brain.
I guess there's some burst of happiness
that comes out of that.
They talk about this in concussion where
the where they don't suffer from brain
trauma or cte.
Actually they don't get.
You think that they would,
but male,
the male rams don't have science and so
the brain is designed different than our
same as a woodpecker.
Woodpecker is brain and fuck it,
they were in my garden are there.
The physiology of the skull was the
both,
but the way their brain is attached to
the inside of the skull is different.
Our brains like barely attached our
brains.
Like someone who's like not worried
about anything bad going wrong.
Well,
it's all gelatinous,
like our spinal cord goes brain and it's
all one big sort of gelatinous mass,
right?
Yes.
Well we're just not sturdy,
you know,
we're just so weak in comparison to
other animals like you,
you know what it's like,
like you remember when you shot your
deer in Montana and we were um,
we were cleaning it and addressing it
and we're pulling on the skin.
You're grabbing that which,
which a lot of people turn into jackets
and pants and shit.
That's the native Americans just make
clothes on them and you're grabbing that
hide and you're thinking,
oh,
this is so thick.
Like this shit is strong.
You're pulling on it and then grab your
bitch ass scale.
We have toilet paper scan,
nick it and it's a process,
you know,
while we were cleaning that animal,
what were,
um,
when you were doing the ravine comer.
I remember I sliced my finger open,
just touched my finger with the blade
and my fingers squirting all over the
place.
Meanwhile,
I've got to really dig in to get to this
meet.
I gotta really cut through all this
skin.
It's so hard.
Yeah,
and then you get an infection,
like if you got a blister on your foot
and you're in the wilderness,
you know who you're fucked,
you're fucked.
You got a lot of guys get because they
were new boots that go,
oh,
I'll go through new boots going hiking
is awesome.
And then your features get.
Fuck what bitches.
We are on the cold too.
We can't handle the call.
I've got some negative messages.
I member on twitter when the episode of
mediator came out when you and I were
uh,
in Montana and I was like,
don't blow into being comfortable.
It's the cool though.
You focus.
This is poor woodsmanship.
Like,
Hey,
poor woodman's ship.
Let's.
Hey,
I'm not a good woodsmen.
I'm a pussy.
It's 90 degrees outside.
You don't want.
You just want me to suck it up.
Does that make you feel better if I just
suck it up?
How about if I say it sucks and then I
suck it up.
Hunting.
Camping here.
You shaking.
I can hear you shivering in the morning,
right here,
putting on your socks and you go get
almost yourself camping.
Blow.
Do you know what doesn't blow when the
campaign is over the best?
Like you have the best showers ever.
We have great.
We have the greatest time to though.
It's fast.
So much fun because we laugh so hard.
I think Rinella wants to go to Mexico
with us.
I want to go.
Okay.
Let's like you guys don't invite me
anymore.
I want to do.
I told them.
I told him the next one to come because
we did one where we struck out we win a
bow hunting for deer in Arizona.
Not Arizona.
Excuse me.
In Nevada last,
uh,
I think it was August.
Nothing struck out.
Was it cold or very hot?
Very hot.
100 degrees.
Real?
Yeah.
So hot that if you shot an animal,
there's a real concern about getting the
meat back to camp as quickly as
possible.
Yeah.
It's fucking hot.
Tj dillashaw Tommy.
He was up in the mountains of a Nevada
in Nevada.
And it was super cold though.
Yeah.
That was like,
what time of year?
Yeah,
he was probably in a different season
and maybe for elk,
you know,
like he was a nice thing.
It was a deer.
Well,
there's a,
there's always a bunch of seasons too,
right?
There's like early archery,
which is what we were doing,
which is where the animals are in
velvet,
so they've just finished growing their
horns and they're starting to scrape the
velvet,
which is the outer skin off of the bone.
I didn't even know until really recently
that antlers are literally bone and an
elk antler.
Like those antlers right there.
That's the fastest growing bone in the
wild kingdom.
Wow.
The fastest growing thing in nature,
those antlers fall off every year.
Every year they weigh 30 pounds.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
They're like 15 pounds each side.
The bone and it grows in a couple of
months.
What?
Yup.
Goes quick.
Yeah.
Like,
see if you could find a video.
Do you see any,
um,
uh,
growth of a elk antlers were when you
were in Nevada,
like in 100 degree heat?
Did you see any other animals?
Okay.
Yeah.
Someone saw an elk.
Um,
uh,
we saw,
we saw some,
a lot of like jack rabbits and stuff
like that.
They have a lot of rabbits.
You have to be really careful with the
rabbits too.
Like if you,
if you kill one and skin one,
they have little mites and shit that
will give you infections that you can
die from.
Lack,
like legitimately see antlers.
Well,
antlers are growing.
They're covered in fuzzy skin called
velvet.
Yeah,
that's what they look like in their
environment.
Is that what you still get that little
quick look?
A quick as mass human growth hormone in
it or.
I mean like.
Yes,
yes,
the velvet from the antlers.
A lot of football players were taking it
because it actually lets you grow growth
hormone.
So look,
you could see it April eighth,
then the April Fifteenth,
and then April 22nd.
Look how quick that Shit's growing.
That's crazy.
Seven days later.
It's longer.
Look at that.
May sixth.
It's fucking gigantic now.
That's nuts.
Look at that.
May Thirteenth,
May 20th a week late like a mushroom,
a week later.
His past as a fucking mushroom.
That is crazy.
A week later after that and it's all
value.
That's nuts.
That is nuts.
July first.
Look at that just a couple of months.
July eighth,
July 15th.
Look at the size of that thing.
Okay.
This must be a commercial elk farm that
we're looking at because these elk are
so big,
like their antlers are so big that that
seems like it seems like,
um,
like they're feeding in something.
It'd be hard to get that many pictures
of the same one too.
Yeah.
That must be.
So.
Let me just pause.
Pause right there.
Yeah,
it is.
If you saw that elk in the wild,
you would shut your fucking pants.
That would be the boulevard bowls.
If its antlers.
Look at the size of the antlers on that
thing.
That thing has like one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine points on one side.
And one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine.
It's a nine by nine.
That's crazy.
Craziest.
Not Have Antlers.
No.
They don't have antlers,
but every now and then a dear female has
antlers.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Some freak bitch just likes to fight
fucking some bull dyke sort of dikey.
Dykey doe just grows them.
Antlers.
Yeah.
Some gunshot one recently.
And they were all confused.
It was white.
It was a,
it was a female rather.
And had a antlers.
They're like,
what is this?
Yeah,
but that should grows every year.
People go shit on to Mexico.
I don't know,
maybe deer.
There's a lot of deer in Mexico.
So Nora.
So Nora has a lot of mule deer.
Dangerous though,
aren't there a bunch?
Don't be scared.
They're not going to fuck with you.
What you gotta worry about is uh,
I mean if you would go to their towns
and caused problems,
you went to just say no to drugs.
They're busy making drug money.
They don't have time to go looking for
some asshole.
Shoot a deer.
And there's branches that you go to out
there were there,
they'd normally they're hunting ranches.
That's why people go there in the first
place.
And that would probably be like where
you park your stuff and you drive in
from Arizona to Cancun.
And one of the guys who's there and
wealth do guy,
and I said,
what about the cartels?
He goes,
they own a lot of these resorts to your
money for them,
they don't worry about the cartels.
And I've talked to a guy with this
amazing restaurant and I said,
what about the cartels?
And they said they'd come here and I
said,
wait a minute.
This does show up in a bunch of SUV is
they come,
they tip,
they say,
thanks.
I go,
they don't like extort money.
No.
The only time that happens is if you're
selling drugs out of your restaurant.
If you're selling drugs out of your
restaurant,
they want a piece.
Otherwise you're fine.
It's all ingrained.
It's all like a whole business you say.
Yeah,
it's a business.
Yeah.
Um,
I was in Punta Mita and we took these
golf carts.
They let us take these golf carts to
town.
We're staying at this resort.
And you,
you could,
you leave the resort and when you leave
the resort there is a stark contrast.
Yes sir.
From safety and beautifully manicured
lawns and landscaped grounds to we get
out.
We are maybe 100,
200 yards from the outside and we see a
military base.
It's a very small military base with two
guys with bulletproof vests,
helmets on holding.
I don't know what kind of fucking high
powered rifle are behind a metal plate
that's attached to the top of a jeep.
So they literally area in like riot war
type vehicle.
Yeah,
fully armed,
ready to go.
So if anything went wrong right over
there,
they drive in so they're protecting this
resort and I realized like protective is
sword.
That's what it's for.
They're there to protect all these
wealthy people from Europe and America
and wherever the fly in stay at this
resort.
And I was like Whoa,
this is crazy because it makes sense.
I mean why else would that be there?
It's there and they're like waiting
outside the gate.
There's a,
there's a,
there's a great deal to be said about
having institutions you can trust like
courts that can enforce contracts that
are not corruptible.
So in this country,
if you buy a house,
that piece of paper actually means
something.
And most countries not so much.
It's your private property,
but somebody with a bigger guy come and
take it from me as we can decide you did
something wrong and they have to take
it.
Yeah,
and that is the fundamental difference
between our countries still and a lot of
other countries,
including Mexico and someplace.
Well,
that's what happened to that McAfee guy
in.
Where was it that he was at?
Was it Costa Rica?
Where was he?
No,
somewhere else that you remember.
That guy,
the McAfee guy that came up with that
virus software and then he went bananas
and moved to some other country,
some tropical country.
What happened to as well?
They accused him of murder.
Was it billy's?
They accused him of murder and he had to
flee the country and they took his land
and he was like,
Hey,
they're their railroad in me.
I gotta get the fuck out of here.
We actually talked to him on the podcast
when he was on the Lam.
He called me up on the phone and I did
an interview with him on the lamb.
It's what happens.
Yeah,
he was a.
He gets.
He's living in America now,
but he's like a bonafide wild man,
like he denied these reports that
there's a forum where someone was taking
photos of method they were making and
explaining how their re-engineering meth
and making it better.
And uh,
they were saying that it was him,
that he was the one who was doing that.
He,
so he's in beliefs get some fucking lab
in his backyard.
He denied the whole thing.
So I don't know if it's true or not
true.
I think he said he was trolling like,
okay,
maybe.
Right.
Remember that Jamie.
It was something connected to like bath
salts,
like he figured out how to reengineer
bath salts and make them better people.
Can you know what's going to happen if
you take.
Nobody took.
Nobody had a lot of problems and then
took some meth and they got better.
Here's my question though.
How many people are doing math right?
And we just don't hear about it.
Yeah.
Meth labs and dead dogs.
So the founder of McAfee antivirus went
on the run and believes Meth,
meth labs.
And it was about the dogs.
When it say what?
Scroll back and dead dogs.
Oh,
okay.
Dead Dogs.
I don't know the story.
He says he was trolling about the meth
labs,
but it's entirely possible.
That dude was just part is as often
believes somebody wind up accusing
somebody of murder and I think they
wanted to question him and he was like,
fuck,
you think I'm gonna?
Move back to America.
I tried this out.
It's not fun guys.
Yeah.
I'll just blog about you for a couple of
years.
What's he do for money?
He started McAfee antivirus.
I'm sure he's got millions of dollars.
They took a lot of his cash though.
That's a huge problem.
That's the problem with Russia and a lot
of countries when when like the ruling
elite has the power to do whatever they
want,
including kill you.
You guys take your house.
It's this double agent in England today.
London.
He and his daughter are gravely ill.
Been poisoned.
Yeah.
There were.
There were secret agent against Russia,
right?
Yeah.
Double agents I guess.
Don't do that.
Well,
you're gonna you're gonna die.
Yeah.
That seems like a bad job.
Secret agent against Russia.
That's a risky fucking job.
Did you see it,
Chris?
Have you seen that?
Yes,
I have.
Boy.
One a Oscar for that Disney did and well
deserved.
Well deserved.
We know where that Russian scientists.
I love that guy.
That guy is under protection.
He is right now under protective custody
somewhere where they're worried about
him being assassinated.
They they took.
Not only did they take all of his money,
they took away his wife's house.
They did?
Yeah.
They.
They're trying to turn his family.
Homeless.
I think they're trying to pressure him
into going back to Russia and giving
himself up by making his family
essentially homeless.
Yeah.
They're putting tremendous pressure on
him so he can't get his wife out or
anything.
Or Gregory.
What is his last name?
Gagarin.
He doesn't as well,
but I would have gotten wiser
apparently.
He.
She didn't want to listen.
She didn't want to come.
He was already out of the country and he
didn't.
She didn't want to listen to him and she
didn't understand that he had been.
They were listening to his phone calls
and emails that she didn't have a way.
He didn't have a way of expressing to
her like,
hey,
you've gotta get the fuck out now.
Like if you did that,
they would have just come and scooped
her up.
No due process.
Rod Shanoff Gregory watching off the
head of the Russian anti-doping
laboratory.
It's an amazing documentary folks.
If you haven't seen it,
it's on Netflix man.
But it just shows you what it could be
like in other countries.
They don't play by the rules.
There's no rules.
He who has the power makes the rules.
That's right.
You're,
you're dealing with the mafia basically
organized bad.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of people that love it
to be like that here.
Oh,
they would love it.
I know.
And they don't because they have no idea
of what history is about.
Here's the thing,
if you want to use this,
if you,
if you want to be,
if you don't want to believe in things
like due process,
right?
Um,
integrity of courts and all those
things,
uh,
if you don't want to,
if you don't want to believe that you
should have a right to criticize your
government.
I know what works for you right now
because the person in power is on your
side,
but you're next.
You're next.
As soon as the tables flip and the
table's always flip,
so you are historically ignorant.
There is a reason that the founding
fathers thought through these things.
They came from tyranny and uh,
the,
the genius of the founding fathers was
there's those checks and balances and
representative government.
And it's such a radical idea that our
leaders are basically are they serve at
our whim?
Now that's all changing.
Lawrence lessig you need to have on the
podcast who wrote republic last.
I talk about them all the time.
Lawrence lessig will tell you right now.
He's a,
he's a,
he's at Harvard University.
He's a law professor.
And he said,
your government does not represent.
You have the Gerrymander districts where
there are all these districts are
gerrymandered.
You know what that means.
So the congressional districts are
essentially,
they're redrawn so that they favor one
party or another.
Do you understand?
So demographics,
so a million Republicans in
Massachusetts as well,
not vote.
They're never going to win.
They're just not represented.
Because the districts are so
gerrymandered that it's always going to
be typically a democrat.
That's one example.
Okay.
Of the 435 seats in Congress,
the ones that aren't chairman and the
ones that are actually where your vote
actually counts there,
about 35 of those seats,
about 35 of the 40,
35.
I think that's the number.
Just keep this in mind to every fucking
congressmen that you know spends 30 to
70 percent of his or her time calling
for money raising funds and they do sent
30 to 70 percent of their time.
That's insane.
And they do it.
And this has been well documented in
republic last and so damn much money.
There are some very good books that I've
read on this.
I've had less sick on my podcast.
Why's he got to have him on because he's
a fucking important.
I'd be happy to.
He's so important to listen to.
And he had his spells name Lawrence
lessig s l e s s I g and he does an
amazing job.
He's got a great ted talk.
You can listen to her for 20 minutes.
That's all it is,
and just listen to him talk about how
democracy doesn't work the way it does
with money in politics now,
and he talks about campaign.
We just so when you didn't say campaign
finance,
reform everybody's zones out that those
words are exhausting.
I'm like,
oh Jesus.
But he opens the book with this fucking
amazing,
thorough quote and he talks about if you
want to talk about the problems in this
country and our democracy and this
thorough quote is,
I see men everywhere hacking at the
branches of evil while none are striking
at the root.
It's a great fucking quote,
right?
Him Throw Hudson good ones.
Yes,
he had some good ones because that,
those,
some of those data and my,
my other favorite mark twain quote,
a loyalty to my country,
always to my government only when it
deserves it.
It's two really cool quotes,
but you know,
he does a really good job of saying that
35 seats really matter and those are the
only ones that matter with those
districts worth voting.
You know,
where it makes sense to vote,
where if you're,
if you're a republican or a Democrat,
where that,
where that to contested seat,
but then those,
those concussions,
congressional,
you know,
candidates or those ones were in Qa or
in the,
in the seat's already.
They have to raise money to stay in
power.
So they're talking to their donors and
their fundraisers are the ones that are
telling them what kind of issues they
better hit on if they want the big
donors.
That's so crazy.
It's a crazy system.
You know what's interesting though,
the system has affected the place where
we came from.
Like what if the United States didn't
take off from Europe?
What if we didn't bail and start this
thing up over here?
What would it be like over there?
Because what it was like over there was
a bunch of kings and queens and shit and
had been like that forever.
That's right.
And now now it's kind of,
they have a queen,
but it's bullshit.
You know,
there's one prince was getting married
that,
you know,
people who seem to give a fuck about.
I don't get it.
You know,
George George Washington said right when
they wanted to make him king,
he said,
I didn't fight this revolutionary war to
become George the second and George
George King George was the king over
there,
and when King George found out that
George Washington refuse to kingship and
said,
no,
I'm a president and I will serve a term
and I'll go back to month Jello.
Wherever he's from,
was that Jefferson or whatever,
either way,
said or Mount Vernon.
And he said,
uh,
short came to our said if he said that
he's the greatest man to airlift to be
rejected power.
But that's what George Washington said.
I fought.
I fought against.
What's amazing is that it's affected
their,
like the goal of this works better
because it does,
but how did it set in over there?
That's what's fascinating.
Like how did it eventually they gave up
power to sort of emulate the west.
Well,
the British,
the British always had a tradition of so
way before the revolutionary war,
way before the American experiment.
There was always,
in fact the thing it started with Henry
the eighth.
There was always a contentious debate
about how much power the king should
have versus parliament,
how much power the king should have
versus the landed gentry verse.
It was always that issue,
but it's kind of lyricists that the king
doesn't have to show any merit like
they.
They didn't rise through the ranks by
hacking their way through a river of
enemy.
They didn't.
They didn't just figure out a way to
bring prosperity to the land and so
voted them at as king.
Well actually,
it's actually fascinating that this
small island,
the small island of Pale people,
basically controlled almost the entire
world on.
One of the things that's given credit is
that the British had this sort of
religious idea almost.
It was called the great chain of being
and the great chain of being was you
have God at the top,
king is second place,
then you have the aristocracy,
then you have the nobility,
the landed gentry,
and then the surface,
and if you and for you to aspire out of
your place,
your,
your God given place for you to say,
I may be an aristocrat or Nobel or
Atlanta Gentry,
but someday I'm going to be the king.
That would be considered fucking heresy.
That would be the equivalent of us
saying,
I think white people are better than
black people today.
I mean,
it would be to do that and use it as a
quote.
Yeah,
exactly.
You're gonna get in trouble.
I know.
They're going to isolate him and say
that with you.
You have to pause in between each one,
so in other words,
God to speak,
speaking.
You're right.
I worry about that stuff,
but you.
You would not do that.
But that created an incredible order and
it created a very,
very good system to get shit done.
When people all were in their place
doing their duty.
It was very easy to organize,
right,
but not to innovate changes like America
has done.
No,
but the Brits were vendors because they.
They did fine,
but what I'm saying is they don't have
the freedom that they had over here.
If you don't have caste system,
you have the ability to rise from the
bottom to the top.
Now we're here.
That's right.
Like that.
That is what is most attractive about
America as potential potential.
That's why we haven't had revolutions.
That's why we don't have the poor
confiscating the wealth of the rich
because a lot of for him to believe
they're going to be rich.
That's a huge.
That's a huge issue.
Now I have a lot of friends that have
come over from England,
man,
and they just talk about that,
like how you could actually do something
here and people are supportive.
Yeah.
They don't shoot you down.
Like he said,
there's a thing that happens over there
where they.
They don't want to see anybody succeed.
They try to put you in your place and
they try to downplay the possibility of
your success.
Right.
To your face.
It's very gauche to try to aspire.
Scandinavia has the same issue.
It's it's old Europe thinking,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's got to be exhausting.
It's why when along a France started
talking about taxing the rich,
75 percent of their income,
it was met with a great deal of support
because it wasn't workable,
but it was,
you know,
there's always been a real suspicion
Europe of people with too much money
because they become aristocracy and they
become oppressive.
Well,
that's the echoed,
but what you're hearing today about the
elite,
the one percenters,
you know,
the,
the problem with wealth inequality in
this country,
it's called Marxism wealth inequality,
man.
It's called.
It's called a march where we're dealing
with cultural Marxism and,
and you know,
that's always going to be there.
It's always gonna be the,
it's a very easy,
good guy,
bad guy thing.
What?
People don't realize that wealth is
always changing,
so you,
you don't,
you don't start wealthy.
A lot of people started poor then that
got wealthy than they lost their money.
They got wealthy again.
There is however,
a concentration of have a great deal of
wealth and in very few hands,
you know,
if you look at Google,
Amazon and apple and facebook,
I think the only employ about 500,000
people total and they have so much
wealth.
So you know,
the,
the question is what do we do about
universal income?
Yeah,
it's crazy and I think this is all going
to come to a head with Ai.
I really do.
I think things are going to be automated
in a way that nobody has a job.
Yeah,
I think it's going to eliminate all
driving jobs.
I think that's within 20 years of our
life we're going to be looking back at
driving your own car.
The way we look back at drum brakes.
I know.
So now what,
what do we do with human question?
Very good question.
With an outdated piece of machinery.
Like,
um,
is it manufacturing,
you know,
that we need robots for and maybe
there's other things other than driving
manufacturing and driving.
Maybe there's other people will be to
put your tray into a,
you know thing.
Burger flipping robot.
Flippy starts shifted.
Kally Burger.
There you go.
You got a burger flipping robot so it
was going to get a perfect burger.
You're not going to have some kid
talking about pussy.
Forgetting about your burger.
You get to Overcook Burger.
Yeah,
right.
There you go.
So if that's the case,
then it seems to me that we are.
We have to figure out what to do with
all this leisure time,
but we have to pay people.
It could be real weird man.
It can.
I think it's one of those things.
It's creeping up on us.
Show to like the Internet creeped up on
us.
Like the Internet came out of nowhere.
All of a sudden everyone had access to
any answer to any question you ever
wanted.
You could watch videos on anything.
You could learn how to do anything
online.
I mean there's a youtube video where you
can learn basically how to crochet.
You could learn how to Tan your own
leather.
You could learn how to build a bomb.
You can fucking do anything.
You can just constantly be taking in
information.
That's just the beginning.
I think one day within the next 10,
20 years,
they are going to have everything
automated before it's artificial
intelligence.
It's just going to be in a super
efficient robot that can do whatever
task you program it to do.
It's going to be way better at it than
people.
It'd be pointless to have a person do
that thing and then we got to decide
what to do with all these people and
there's got to be.
It could be.
A lot of us are going to be a lot of
clips.
Yeah,
so what do we do?
Is that what they're calling it?
Forty seven percent of a cover of a
magazine.
What is it?
Humility is the new smart is this book
about this 47 percent of all jobs that
we know of now,
at least in this country are going to be
obsolete in the next 20 years.
Do you think we'll adapt?
Yes.
Human beings are.
Yeah,
we'll adaptable.
I hope we just get more creative.
I hope people start doing things more
with their hands already are we already
are.
I mean there's,
there's more access to expressing
yourself.
The problem is it becomes like the call
to the amateur where you just got a lot
of bullshit out there,
but I do think that we will be in a
place.
Well,
like,
you know,
if you look at where our philosophy.
So,
so,
uh,
what was it the rise of,
of European Western civilization.
What the fuck was it?
Oh,
uh,
anyway,
if you look at like how the Greeks were
able to export timber wine and olive
oil,
it gave their economy some money and
they had leisure time.
They didn't have to live on subsistence.
They could trade for things that they
needed as opposed to making them
themselves.
So the Greece,
ancient Greece was fairly wealthy and
comparison and it gave a large sector of
their population,
at least the Richard population time to
do things like not be in the fields all
day,
but rather time to sit around,
eat and think and talk.
Right?
Which,
sure.
Which is probably where a lot of like
socrates and Plato and Aristotle
benefited from.
Right?
Sure.
So you wonder like as as we get to a
point where we don't have to so much,
it becomes very easy to keep our bodies
in homeostasis,
right?
Keep our bodies when they're at the
right temperature and we just need a
certain amount of food and shelter and,
and then you've look a cheap
entertainment is.
I mean look at Netflix man.
It's 10 bucks a month.
You can watch anything you want forever.
Sure.
So then like what do we do man?
What do we do with our time?
Well we,
we didn't have to think about what we're
going to do from 18,
20 to 2020.
We didn't have to think about it.
It just sort of happened and I think
that's going to happen as well,
but I think we're going to have to
adjust.
Obviously the advice we give to children
as far as what's necessary,
what's not necessarily tell them,
I don't know what to tell your kids
either.
That's the thing.
They're going to have to figure it out
as they go along,
but they got to be flexible.
You know,
and I also think,
and this is why I've been thinking this
a lot lately,
I think we have to move.
I think California is over fucking
populated and I think it's going to get
to a point in our lifetime or it's not a
smart place to be.
Really.
Yeah.
This way too many people.
I mean,
you know,
you go to the airport all the time,
that drive.
I had to do it the other day at 8:00
in the morning,
I was like,
this is hilarious.
Or you'll get to a point where you don't
have to fly.
You want to fly.
You'll get to a point where that's true,
but the sheer number of people,
if anything goes wrong all in this one
spot,
it's just not wise.
It doesn't feel good.
Yeah.
I always feel unsafe.
It doesn't feel good.
It feels like people aren't that
valuable.
They're everywhere.
There were infested with the a futurist
who said,
you've got to learn how to learn,
unlearn,
and relearn.
And that's the only way we're going to
survive in the 21st century.
I'm not really worried about pupils
survive and I think we're going to be
okay in that regard.
The lungs,
we don't get hit by anything like we
don't get potent or we don't get hit by
an asteroid or we don't get hit by a
super volcano,
which are all.
All those things are actually really
possible.
I mean,
no one wants to think that we can get
attacked by Russia,
but for sure we can.
All sorts of weird scenarios can present
themselves in this wacky life with a
bunch of things falling into place and
the wrong way.
All of a sudden you got World War Two.
It's happened.
I mean,
that's just the nature of humans.
And if we deny the past,
we don't have that was then we're
different.
Now.
If we don't look at this rationally,
we can realize how precarious we are
now.
That is just one thing that we can kind
of control.
Hopefully human beings can control their
impulses to fucking hit the button.
Now they have.
What's his name?
Nassim Taleb talks about the Black Swan,
so know that there's always a black
swan,
know that the aberration know that
history is full of things you never saw
coming.
Hitler,
a financial crisis,
the housing crisis,
I mean it goes on and on and history is
full of that.
Most wars start as a weekend skirmish
and people kind of leave for the
weekend,
leave all this stuff and it's going to
be over.
And before you know it,
it,
it's,
it's a 30 year civil war that happened
in Lebanon.
That's where tellabs from,
so that you've got to at least know that
you're going be able to predict the
future,
but know that they're the unpredictable.
Always be present and we'll always take
what you took to be reality and flip it
on it's fucking head.
And I think robotics and I think ai are
certainly,
you know,
that tidal wave.
Do you worry at all about super power
struggles between the United States and
China and United States and Russia?
Way less only because I think that
there's less,
there's less profit in violent warfare.
Uh,
it just doesn't profit anybody this way,
more profit in trade and dealing with,
you know,
you're going to have issues like this
tariff issue,
but for the most part,
the,
so,
so the biggest advantage is that there
isn't a whole lot of advantage for a
country to take over territory because
that's not what makes you
wealthier.
So if Russia came in and took over
silicon valley,
there's nothing that take off about
doing that,
I think.
But that's typically what dropping a
bomb somewhere.
What they're saying is essentially that
they're not talking about invading the
United States.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
They would never do that.
The real question is what unless they
nuked us for why would they drop a bomb
where there might be some reason why
they feel backed into a corner to
interest in the United States?
Sure.
Yeah.
It's not likely unless they feel like
there was some way where they would
benefit extremely well from having us
debilitate it.
It's not likely because we would attack
back and it's mutually assured
destruction.
Right.
But the fact that a person could make
the decision whether or not to do that
or whether or not that's logical and
you're relying on a person who's
essentially a murderous dictator running
this fucking crazy halfass government
over there.
I mean,
what is he doing over there?
you just from what you know about Russia
state sponsored doping program with that
guy and went straight up to Putin,
everybody knew what the fuck they were
doing.
They were doing it on purpose because
like,
I mean,
there's,
that's a crazy country band.
It's crazy and it's 2018.
It's still crazy.
It's A.
Well,
it's run by the one idea which is might
makes right that the male with the
biggest club is the male that,
that calls all the shots.
My,
my.
That's a big concern with me.
Um,
but my real big concern are natural
things,
pandemics,
pandemic,
virus or accidents,
nuclear accidents and earthquakes,
earthquakes.
Um,
the big one for me,
super volcano,
that is an inevitable reality that we're
going to have to face one day.
Whether it's 100 years from now or 10
years from now.
Yellowstone is going to blow,
they don't know when,
but it could be anytime and it could
take out the entire.
The whole continent.
Then.
Yeah,
if the yellowstone blows,
they say every six to 800,000
years.
It's a continent killer.
It just blows and everybody's fucked and
it last time it happened was 600,000
years ago,
so it might be 200,000
years before it happens again and who
knows?
We might figure out how to drill hole in
there and pop it like Dr Pimple Popper.
They received that instagram page.
Sure half.
She's drills a hole in there,
like a pimple on sports.
All that love out and maybe it's okay.
Get outta here.
Yeah,
maybe that'll keep it from blowing up,
but if it blows to the thousands of
earthquakes every year,
thousands,
just constantly moving and rumbling.
It's just loose crust.
And underneath is Chai fantic reservoir
of Melton Rock,
melted rock,
melted rock that shoots into the fucking
Scott giant,
very blood of the earth.
Oh,
it's so big.
They didn't even know it was a volcano
until like,
I think it was 20,
maybe 20 years ago,
they started doing overhead satellite
photos and they're like,
oh Jesus.
And they,
they thought it was just like a hotbed
of Geo solar activity or what it would
be,
not geo solar,
geothermal,
geothermal activity,
you know,
they had an old faithful spray water up
in the sky.
They realized,
oh,
this is something going on underneath
the surface,
and then they get these satellite photos
and they realized,
Holy Shit,
this is a,
this is a crater.
This thing is a crater that used to be a
mountain had exploded and I want to say
it.
Something like,
how wide is the called?
I don't want to mess this up.
I want to say it's like 600 kilometers
wide.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
It's an enormous.
We know is a molten lava as the
coordinator of this.
A bunch of shit down then it's not good.
What is it?
Okay,
got it.
Okay.
No,
it's 35 miles.
Fifty Mile Long.
Okay.
Currently has appeared that you can
read.
There are so many different kinds of
reality.
So the reality that that if you go up
into the stars,
it's a different reality and if you go
wait in the microscopic level,
it's a totally different reality.
Then you can go to the subatomic level.
Look at this.
The region's most recent caldera forming
eruption was 640,000
years ago,
creating the 35 mile wide,
50 mile long yellowstone Caldera.
Okay.
I fucked up the distance,
but still,
that's pretty God damn big.
So a 50 mile long,
35 mile wide volcano.
That just blows up to the point where
the tops not there anymore and just
shoots off shit a mile into the sky.
And then you get nuclear winter all over
the globe in anything even remotely
near.
It gets cooked instantly.
Is that right?
Oh yeah.
You fucked.
So we're all dead.
Oh,
we're dead.
It's fuck.
We're dead as fuck.
If yellow's don't blows,
we don't have a chance that people will
talk to the dikes.
I talk to that like Kinda like,
like they'll lose a leg of this bias to
a shark or something or.
And they.
And they ended up dying like,
you know,
they,
they pass out.
Um,
they all said that it was a super
peaceful,
like they just got this overwhelming
sense of peace and they were like,
oh,
I'm going to die now.
Oh yeah.
It's the brain.
The brain's pumping out that dopamine
and dimethyltryptamine and all these
different things to try to transition
you.
Yeah.
But like existence is a weird thing.
What do you think happens?
I don't know,
man.
Oh,
well,
when you go,
my feeling is that talking to this
quantum physicists,
this bad ass dude,
um,
I feel like there must be this idea that
existence is a question of he was
talking about existence is a question of
the question,
what question you,
you're asking or were you standing?
So there,
there are different forms of existence,
right?
So there are different forms of reality.
Like a,
there's the subatomic reality,
there's the Newtonian reality that you
can measure and see we're here.
If I was looking at Los Angeles from a
plane that's a different perspective.
It might be a different kind of reality.
And I think he,
he kinda like said most physicists,
he was trying to explain what existence
is right and how it's meaningless.
And I was like,
what the fuck he talking about,
he's talking about mathematics.
And he said,
he said,
well,
this is a reality to us because of where
we are and the space time continuum that
we're occupying right now.
So we are here and all that you are
experiencing may not may very well not
even be a reality right over in this
direction.
What the would mean.
Say when they sit around with legal
papers all day,
we'll write a bunch of shit and nobody
fucks up.
Well that's,
well,
that's what I mean.
And I said,
what's up?
I go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And he said he's going to win a Nobel
prize.
And he said,
I'm okay.
I guess the best way to put it,
as think of you having a virtual reality
goggles on and you know,
people just splashing water on you as
you're in the water and you're getting
rocked back and forth.
I guess that's the best way to describe
what you,
what you consider to be your reality.
I was like,
all right,
all right.
Maybe,
I dunno.
maybe,
but they seem to be able to prove a lot
of this in like what's fascinating to me
is I didn't know how to get into this,
but like he was talking about how
electrons can communicate with each
other.
I'm like got a sheet of metal and they
don't.
They don't see each other like in terms
of the actions are light years away,
but they completely all work together
and he was talking about how to do.
There's a mathematical way of proving
halls.
There is a mathematical sort of
algorithm that proves that they are.
The answer to that is that there an
invisible conductor,
like something,
a higher intelligence and immersion
intelligence is dictating that
communication intelligence or order an
order.
Right.
But not an intelligence as well.
So it tells us the wrong way to say it.
And he said that to me too,
because I sit intelligent and he said
order and you're right.
So there's an order,
right?
So there's a,
there's an order to the chaos,
right?
So the way schools of fish,
but you know,
schools of fish and birds,
a bird,
guess what else behaves that way,
inert matter,
electrons.
That's one of the things that they think
is going on with birds.
It's one of the reasons why birds have
some sort of internal compass and that
they literally mentality.
They react to the poles of the earth.
Like they know when migrating birds,
they know which way to go.
Like they really do somehow or another,
but they also know not to fly into each
other.
Like when you see them all flying
together and they move in tandem,
it's insane.
It's insane.
It's gorgeous.
And you know,
your brain's the same way.
So the neurons,
there's no reason.
It makes no sense that the neurons.
So each neuron is just essentially an on
off switch or a,
you know,
it's a whatever it is.
But for whatever reason,
all of those neurons have self
organized,
and they self organized.
Okay.
That's what's fascinating.
And the way your brain has self
organized,
so has this sheet of metal and he kind
of proved he sat around and I think he's
38 or 39 and he and he solved this,
this theorem called wholesale,
took them three years to make sure he
was right.
Don't you think that happens?
There's like
a,
like a big mass event like like mob
mentality,
don't you think that's part of what what
is going on with mob mentality and that
things happen and things can get chaotic
and people just go with it.
They'd go with it in mob and I think.
I think the origin of that is probably
survival instincts in war that in war
you have to accept unbelievably barbaric
reality and so you have to be able to
slide into that wherever we're killing
everybody with axes,
let's go and then everybody else is
doing it.
I guess I'm in.
And then he started hacking people up
where you would never do it by yourself
if it was just totally up to you,
but you find yourself getting caught up
in the way in the hive where the human
hive is moving,
that all these people are moving towards
violence or moving towards chaos like
people get wrapped up in these mob
mentality moments in a very,
very bad.
Well
you can also go,
you can actually,
you can step back from that and actually
you can explain that actually when you
look at bacteria,
certain bacteria and certain insect
colonies.
And let me explain.
So somebody like Antonio Damasio who is
a behavioral scientist who wrote a
fucking great book but very dense,
called the strange order of things and
he talks about how human beings behave
in a certain way,
like their feelings are directly related
to their biology because their feelings
are essentially the,
uh,
the voices or the mechanism by which you
know,
whether or not to bring your body back
into homeostasis when it's out of
homeostasis.
Homeodynamic actually stay right?
So in other words,
that mob is probably going in there with
access because they perceive the
feelings are they perceive a threat from
that other group because that other
group is going to take something from
them,
okay,
it's going to either take their
resources,
their children,
whatever it might be,
and take over their territory.
So,
so watch bacteria actually behave the
exact same way and you can put bacteria
into certain like,
um,
and there's a scientist who does this a
lot.
You can put them into certain conditions
where the bacterial behave like that.
They'll do some fascinating things.
Not only will they fucking take over the
other bacteria and go out into an all
out war and kill mercilessly the other
bacteria,
but sometimes when they find they can't
kill that bacteria,
they'll actually cooperate with that
bacteria.
Now,
how about this?
Within the ranks of their own bacteria,
the bacteria that are not pulling their
weight,
that tend to be lazier than the other
bacteria that are the same.
They're the same species.
Those bacteria will be fucking shunned.
There'll be pushed out.
They will not.
People like people,
they're,
they're the weak link insects.
If you look at insect colonies,
they behave very much like human
cultures do.
You got,
uh,
an aunt that's protecting the queen ant
or a b that's protecting the Queen Bee.
You have soldiers that do the fighting.
You have workers that do the working and
they self organize in this incredible
way and nobody's really.
No,
it's not like it's somebody.
It's not a top down thing.
It's sort of a genetically programmed
thing,
but their behavior is very similar.
Their behavior.
So even with bacteria,
when they can't beat this bacteria,
they'll join forces with that bacteria
to defeat the other bacteria that's
weaker and it's fascinating.
So even on the uni cellular level,
you see striking similarities between
humans and even bacteria.
Now add to that the fact that one,
only one in 10 of yourselves as a human
being is actually human and the rest is
bacteria back on it,
that you as a human might be the Patina.
You're just the Patina on a,
on a background of bacteria.
So maybe bacteria is dictating how the
fuck you behave.
Well,
the bacteria is also the outside skin,
inside and outside skin.
Flora is incredibly important.
Yes.
That's why I always recommend people eat
probiotics is one of the things that
helps you with diseases.
Um,
and then natural oil soaps that not non
antibacterial soaps.
That's very important.
So,
so that's right.
So keeping your,
your biodome yeah.
In order,
which is the new science might also be
dictating your very behavior because it
does.
I think when I eat healthier and I eat a
lot of probiotics,
I feel more at ease.
I feel more comfortable.
I heard you have to be careful with
probiotics because you can throw off
your gut level two.
And what are you eating now?
I'm eating it.
Food Miles.
I've decided a long time ago that you
can take some probiotic pills and stuff
like that.
And I definitely take someone on the
road.
I bring that on a total gut health
because I'm,
I'm on the road.
I know what the fuck.
I want to make sure I'm getting good
food.
But a mom at home,
I eat a lot of fermented vegetables.
I've been,
I've been to the,
a lot of that,
I eat Kimchi like almost everyday
because you're an extremist and I know,
you know,
but it's,
it is good if you feel good,
drink a lot of that shit.
That Kombucha is fucking phenomenal.
That gts Kombucha.
I heard a uh,
some oh,
somebody in my family got a endometrial
cancer and the doctor said the surgeon
who deals with this exclusively said,
do me a favor,
just don't drink these for awhile.
Whoa.
And she goes,
why?
And he said,
I can't prove this yet,
but I see a direct link between this
type of cancer and women who drink a lot
of probiotic drinks like this.
No Shit.
Yes.
CV,
find anything on that.
Women drink probiotic drinks cause
cancer.
And this is a women's drinks martinis.
Blowjobs.
Put that all together.
Hey man,
come on dude.
That's too much.
Just kidding.
That would be terrifying man.
If that was the case.
Well I would think maybe there's a
certain level,
like if you,
a nutty person
who drank like really powerful Kombucha
all day.
Like all you drank is Kombucha.
Yeah.
Like your body might be overwhelmed,
extremist and anything,
right?
I mean you gotta have balance.
The question is this to what's the
metric for how many vitamins you need
and then on top of that,
if you have enough,
what is adding more to that do?
Does it help you or doesn't do?
Nothing.
Does do harm.
Is it,
is it the same for you as it is for
Brendan?
Is it the same for me?
Like how is there a US da when
everybody's body so radically different
size,
different know like w how come a
thousand milligrams is good for this guy
and it's not good for him.
I think that there's a lot of people too
that are probably just not getting the
right fucking combinations of food too,
you know,
like just need to experiment,
figure out what's the right combinations
of things for you.
Like that was what the whole gracie diet
was based on.
The gracie diet was based on,
um,
you shouldn't eat certain foods and
combination because the enzymes that are
to breakdown fruit or not good to mix
with the enzymes that break down meat,
you should eat them separate from each
other and like they had a bunch of whole
theories about that stuff.
What's your,
what do you,
what do you think if you,
if there were certain truths about diet
after all this time,
like certain truths,
right?
Giant variations between human
requirements.
That's what I found the truth.
I've stopped saying for a long time ago
that you should do this.
One thing you should definitely do is
eat healthy.
Right?
So what's eating healthy?
I don't think there's anything wrong
unless you have some sort of a disease.
with eating a bunch of green leafy
vegetables.
I think that Shit's very important for
you.
I do it.
I feel better when I do it.
My body feels like when I eat like a big
ass salad,
like a spinach salad,
my body was feeling like this was like
he got it in there.
Yeah.
You like,
you got it in there.
That's what I was looking for.
I was looking for them.
Some of that green leafy stuff.
All those Fido nutrients that.
That to me,
that just.
It feels like my body jives with that.
Yep.
Elk Wild game.
Meat tastes better.
Feels differently.
Evolved.
It's different.
It's just different.
I know it is.
Everybody's been saying it forever and
then want to eat it.
I go,
oh whew.
Like it gives you that salad thing times
five.
Right?
It's like woo.
Like when I eat a nice steak,
it feels good.
I like a nice steak,
but it's a lazy nice.
It's a lazy meat.
If I eat a cut into nice American corn
fed steak tastes delicious,
but it's a lazy meat.
I cut into a piece of elk or go like,
oh,
it just rumbles somewhere.
Deepen your DNA.
You eat a deer.
If some of US eating deer,
you're.
Your body's like this motherfucker was
sprinting all day.
You know there's something in there
that's different.
You're eating an animal that has this
vitality to it.
A wild Vitas,
Charles pollock.
When you know the strength coach talks
about,
he goes,
for me,
I have to eat.
My favorite made is the longhorn
antelope in the north of Canada.
They spent a lot of time running away
from wolves,
so you know the glycogen in the is
always there,
always have a high level.
There's a guy who like a meat fudge and
of course you have to kill them from
helicopter.
You can't.
You're not allowed to kill them anywhere
else.
So you should have a helicopter and
there's only one meets two in Toronto
that I go to.
I'm like,
all right,
dude,
take it easy,
but it does sound delicious.
Canada is antelope.
Maybe it's a type of antelope.
Yeah.
It's not Caribou now.
It's a type of antelope I think.
Wow.
Yeah,
and they're.
And they.
Maybe it's terrible,
but I think it's handled up.
Maybe.
I don't know,
but either way they run away from wolves
all day and the glycogen is really high.
We're going axis deer hunting.
Maybe that's going to Hawaii.
It's probably not,
but acts,
deer,
they evolved in India running away from
tigers.
They're an Asian deer and their natural
enemies.
Tigers.
You have never seen an animal.
I shot a deer that was 40 yards away.
It looked at me.
I let the Arrow go.
By the time the Arrow got to it,
it was nowhere near where it was.
My Arrow goes 280 feet per second.
The Arrow,
once it left,
the string was headed towards that thing
at 280 feet per second.
And that deer was nowhere near it.
Wow.
He was six,
seven,
six,
seven feet away,
like gone.
The Arrow went right into the bushes and
he was over there.
You ain't seen nothing like it.
They like from the Matrix.
Let me see an access to your big.
It's about a hundred and 30 to 150
pounds for a big one.
Not quite as big as a white tail,
like a northern White Tilak we hunted
in,
um,
that looks,
that looks a lot bigger than it really
is.
There's like saving and find the
picture.
The one that I shot,
it's online on Cameron Hanes,
instagram page.
I try to keep them off all the dead
animals,
off my instagram page,
send them to my hunter friends.
They post them,
they get so mad.
Right.
They definitely get mad.
People get mad at me while they have a
burger on their page.
People are just goofy.
That's my access to you that I shot.
That's amazing.
That's why that's in Hawaii.
That was why a lot of bugs?
No,
no little tiny ones.
Little bit,
but no.
What it really is,
is a,
a giant that's a pronghorn antelope.
That's a different animal.
It's not an antelope in Canada.
Okay.
Because I know they're in Montana and
Wyoming.
One Shit.
Okay.
Oh,
they're on a coin down the south.
No,
I don't think so.
I don't think I've been.
No,
nope.
Just Texas.
Texas is not the south though.
Um,
so if we could organize something for
Mexico urine,
I'm down.
I think it will use rifles.
So it'd be easy for me now.
Yeah,
you brought me that bowl.
Have yet to know.
But you can't go bow hunting without.
Especially if we go.
Yeah,
after dear.
Like I said with that thing one,
if you don't do it the right way,
yeah,
well it's just,
it's just something.
If you want to really do it,
you got to get obsessed with it the
first time you do it.
It should be in a controlled
environment,
like one of the first way would really
be a good way would be wild pigs over
bait because there's a lot of places
where they try to eradicate these wild
pigs so they have feeders and the
feeders of go off in the wild pigs are
almost like conditioned to go near the
feeder and then when they go near the
feeder,
you know exactly the distance because
they're right underneath the feet are
the feeders 20 yards away from you and
you have a controlled shot and it's easy
and it's an animal that they must kill,
so there's not like a number of them
that you can hunt.
Can't believe how many there are.
There's so many.
If you're in Texas,
they shoot them out of helicopters.
They fly around in helicopters and gun
the.
They still say you can't shoot your way
out of the problem.
Well,
they're doing their best to at least do
something about it.
They're not going to shoot their way out
of the problem to the point of
extinction.
They.
They move so quick.
There's so many of them.
They're smart,
tough as shit,
and they have litters three or four
times a year.
Yeah.
They just constantly running around
other moms.
What are the ones that I saw?
There's one eating out of a garbage can
in the Asia.
Those got to be in.
Those are not wild pigs.
Those are wild boars.
Well,
board just means a male of female is a
sound.
Some of those ones that you see,
they have got a razorback.
They're just like those.
They look like they're not as big as
pigs,
but they're just fierce looking at.
Well,
it's just because the supply of food,
if they had as much pigs as wild boar,
right.
That's.
Oh yeah.
That's a real wild boar,
man.
That's a big ass pig.
That doesn't look like a real pig,
honestly.
That almost looks like a wart hog.
Yeah,
it does.
So big.
But here's the thing about wild pigs,
man.
This is something I learned from my pal,
Steve Rinella.
They are literally all the same animal,
wild pigs and domestic pigs.
They're the same animal.
It's called [inaudible].
They're all part of one gigantic
species.
Poor capturing the size of that thing
that looks like a power lifter.
Yeah.
The thing is it looks like it's like 400
pounds as long as snout is just tiny
little bitch ass feet,
tiny feet.
That doesn't even seem real.
That seems like an animal.
And like,
um,
like a Beatles cartoon.
Like the nowhere man,
you know,
his proportions were all I think about
John Jones and how skinny his legs are
and what a fucking beast he is.
And then you look at his legs was like,
you got some pencil legs strong as shit
too.
He's strong as shit with her legs.
Yeah.
Chael and said he'd be cradled him.
Said it was.
He did.
Didn't he?
Cradle Ryan Bader.
Yeah.
He smoked Ryan Bader.
He smoked.
He choked out.
Ryan Bader.
He smokes everybody.
He's.
He's ridiculously strong.
He's ridiculously strong too when it
comes to like dead lifting and shit too.
He does a lot of power lifting now so
strong when he was going to happen with
him.
I don't know.
I want to see him fight Steve Bay.
I want to see them fight brock.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what Brendan and I were just
saying.
This is the card.
Steep a DC.
John Jones,
Brock Floyd Mayweather,
cm punk Hoffeld dose on Joe's Tyron
Woodley.
There's your paper view.
Here's your papers.
You.
You're welcome.
It's kind of crazy.
You will go.
I want to see the Khabib.
Tony Ferguson.
I'm very excited.
Once you come to Brooklyn,
what do you do in April seventh if I'm
not.
Actually,
I shouldn't plug some dates.
Come on,
you can come see me this weekend.
Okay.
Alabama.
I'm a stand up live in Huntsville,
Alabama with April around April seventh
because I'll be at the uh,
New York West Palm to New York,
West Palm Improv.
April twelfth,
13th.
14th,
everybody.
So come see me.
But wait,
April seventh.
Yeah,
I can come to.
Then I can come to that.
I think Brendan's going to be in town
too,
so hold on.
It's doing something for up.
And then we'll do,
I'll do it.
I would come.
Alright.
We're coming for real,
uh,
is going to be there too,
although I'm not supposed to say.
All right.
What's that?
Oh yeah.
Oh,
we'll leave with this.
This is a,
we have this thing we're doing.
Our friend Paulie tune is a,
a guy that is now taking.
We've hired him to take sections of the
podcasts that are funny and turn them
into these animated clips and they're
fucking amazing.
He's really talented.
And you can get them on the powerful jre
youtube channel.
I think there's like a whole group of
them is a playlist for them and he's
made a ton of them and they're awesome.
So here's one,
it's a bad breath moment.
This is with a,
from a fight companion with Callan,
Jimmy Smith,
Eddie and you boom.
Right.
And we're going to wrap this up folks.
So that's it for now.
My next gigs are.
The only thing that I have where there's
some tickets available is New Orleans,
New Orleans,
which is,
um,
March 15th,
I think.
Said it.
Yes.
Thursday night,
March 15th.
There's some tickets available for the
second show.
Everything else is.
I think it's down to like single
tickets.
Oh,
the Ice House in Pasadena.
I still haven't put this on twitter.
I'm going to eventually,
but the 23rd and the 24th,
uh,
two shows each night.
Twenty third and the 24th was a Friday
and a Saturday.
It's a rare weekend at the ice house.
But um,
Nashville or New Orleans.
Yeah.
I'm doing Nashville too.
But New Orleans in the 15th.
Did I say Nashville early on the 15th
and I say New Orleans.
I said New Orleans,
New Orleans,
New Orleans on the 15th of March,
which is a little over a week from now.
And then the 30th of March.
Nashville,
two shows at the Ryman.
I think they're sold out.
And then two shows in Charlotte.
I don't know how many tickets left to
that either kind of scenario.
It's 10 of Vr this week.
I mean stand up live and Moundsville,
Alabama.
Yeah.
Course.
What are you doing?
You're going to the wrong place.
I live in Huntsville,
Alabama,
so definitely a third this Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
and then West Palm Beach Improv,
April 12,
13,
14.
Maybe they should go to Brian
[inaudible] dot com and there can make
plans or set k.k.com.
All right.
This is a bad breath moment from jre
tunes.
Thank you everybody and we'll be back
tomorrow with the great and powerful
John Dudley.
Maybe Brian could come.
We'll teach them how to shoot a bow.
I'll do it later by everybody and I had
a cracked filling and they took the
filling out and the fucking smell that
came out of my
mouth.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Because there was an infection.
I had to wind up getting a root canal.
It like you could hear it like pop
through and then just this fucking shit
breath that.
My father's,
my father's friend,
he was sleeping.
His wife said you have to go to.
The dentist said,
why does your breath is so out of
control?
So apparently he had an abscess,
a sack of bacteria in the back of his
mouth.
Well,
when they took the feeling out and they
popped by accident,
the sac,
the nurse
through a fucking dentist moment,
a double vomit fest.
So did she puke on him or shouldn't be
gone if she just puked went.
I
like that.
I never have the balls to tell someone
their breaths.
Testing.
You work with them.
You have.
If you work with them,
you have to tell.
Friends would want them to tell me like,
your breath stinks.
I'm going to tell you that one cool
thing about black people,
they'll tell you if Jesus Christ,
that's great.